oui monsieur le
Président vous donz ça
après
bien madame la
présidente de la délégation sénatoriale
aux autr cher Micheline Jacques
messieurs les vice-présidents du Sénat
cher Mathieu dararmau cher Dominique
Théophile chers collègues députés et
sénateurs Mesdames et Messieurs les
présidents d'association de ma mes chers
collègues maire maire adjoint élus
municipaux chers
amis je suis heureux de vous souhaiter
au nombre de l'ensemble des sénateurs
oui de vous souhaiter la bienvenue au
Palais du Luxembourg pour notre
désormais traditionnelle rencontre
organisée par la délégation sénatoriale
au outremer dans le cadre du congrès des
maires de France cette prise de parole
me permet tout d'abord de vous nouvelé
cher Micheline jacqu mes chaleureuses
félicitations pour votre élection la
présidence de notre délégation au
outrebert et de vous adresser mes vet
plus sincères pour le succès de votre
mission
elle me permet également de souligner
l'importance de l'action de votre
prédécesseur notre ancien collègue
Stéphan artanau à la présidence de cette
délégation la qualité le sérieux du
travail qu'il a accompli en fédérant les
énergies de l'ensemble des membres de la
délégation ont largement contribué à
donner une visibilité à vos travaux je
pense en particulier au rapport relatif
à l'avenir institutionnel
outremire cette prise de parole me
permet à cet instant d'avoir une pensée
pensée émue pour notre ancienne collègue
victoire jasmin sénatrice de la
Guadeloupe qui nous a quitté il y a
quelques semaines nous conserveront le
souvenir d'une parlementaire assidue
active tant à la délégation au outrem
que dans l'hémicycle ou encore au bureau
du Sénat où Sié à mes
côtés cet aprs-midi
d'échange je tiensigner un moment
privilégié pour mes cègues et moimême
qui partageons ce même attachement à la
proximité attachement au territoire et
en particulier aux 212 communes
ultramarines disséminées à travers le
monde et qui contribue par la même au
rayonnement de notre
pays mais peut-il en être autrement
alors que le Sénat incarne votre voix la
voie des élus locaux qui assure la
cohésion de notre
République votre présence et vous êtes
nombreux il va falloir qu'on utilise euh
des mézanines me semble-t-il oui votre
présence nombreuse est source de
satisfaction je voudrais saluer les
présidents d'association de ma qui joue
tout au long de l'année un rôle
important dans leur territoire à travers
les conseils qu'ils apportent aux
communes les temps d'échange qu'ils
organise et leur fonction indispensable
de relais auprès des parlementaires en
outre grâce à l'heureuse initiative du
président David lissnard ils peuvent
désormais au sein de la délégation au
outremè de l'Association des maire de
France
uvrer en faveur de leur territoire
auprès des décideurs
nationaux les thèmes retenu pour cet
après-midi d'échange sur l'avenir de la
commune et du maire et l'enjeu de l'eau
c'estes sujets sont particulièrement
d'actualité tant dans l'Hexagone que
dans vos
territoires ils ont fait l'objet d'un
travail approfondi du Sénat et des
préconisations concrètes ici de rapport
de deux missions d'information
leurs auteurs Marie scarer et Mathieu
Darnaud pour le prier terme ainsi que
Rémy Porou et Hervé gilet pour le second
je crois que ils ne manqueront pas de
vous faire part de leurs
réflexion de leurs analyses et de leurs
propositions c'estinroger sur l'avenir
de la commune et du maire apparaît comme
une exigence et je le dis devant la
présidente de la délégation collectivité
territoriale du Sénat Françoise Gatel
particulièrement engagé elle aussi sur
ce sujet depuis plus de 15 ans nous
vivons une recentralisation et par la
même un affaiblissement de la liberté
d'action des élus durant cette période
nos communes ont perdu une grande part
de leur autonomie financière depuis la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
puis de la taxe d'habitation ou
encore c'est en cours de la cotisation
sur la valeur ajoutée des entreprises
pour certaines d'entre elles
je pense aux communes de Polynésie
française et de NouvelleCalédonie son la
dem moi la situation est encore plus
complexe pour ce qui est de la liberté
d'action puisqu'elles dépendent de par
leur statut du financement de l'État et
du transfert du budget du
territoire je souhaite que le futur
statut de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie actuellement en
discussion conforte les communes
calédoniennes
notamment en matière budgétaire car
elles sont un échelon de proximité
indispensable au développement
harmonieux de la société calédonienne et
à la consolidation du vivre ensemble
sujet essentiel du débat nous en
reparlerons bientôt dans le cadre de
notre groupe de
contact en Polynésie française les
délégations de compét du fnois aux
communes et le R
de ces dernières mériteraiit d'être revu
afin de les renforcer en évoquant la
Polynésie française je n'oublie pas le
Souha des élus des îles Marquises ils me
l'ont signifié de profiter d'une
prochaine révision constitutionnelle
pour permettre la création d'une
communauté
d'archipel aux pertes d'autonomie
évoquée s'ajoute de nouvelles craintes
suscité notamment par l'annonce d'une
prochaine réforme en profondeur je
reprends les termes mêmes de la première
ministre de l'oroit de mer
important pour les collectivités qui le
perçoiv une telle annonce doit nous
inciter à la plus grande vigilance
lorsque l'on sait que cet aut TR de mer
rapporte plus de 1,5 milliards d'euros
aux collectivités
concernées aussi a-je demander au
rapporteur général du budget de
constituer un groupe de travail avec
collègues de la commission des finances
très au fait de ces questions et ce en
lien avec notre délégation aux
outrem nous avons pleinement conscience
de l'importance des conséquences
éventuelles de cette réforme pour vos
territoires car l'roit de mer en plus
d'être une ressource majeure s'avère
être un outil
ant l'accompagnement de la production
locale le Sénat a toujours été présent
sur ce dossier comme le monent les
travaux de notre délégation en 2020 je
les rappelle et notamment en travaux en
faveur de son maintien je pense qu'il
sera tout aussi attentif aujourd'hui et
demain outre ces difficultés et ses
craintes l'État et le Parlement doivent
tenir compte des situations financières
assez dégradées de beaucoup de vos
collectivités qui ne permettent ni
l'investissement local ni le plein
emploi des crédits budgétaires qui leur
sont alloués je le dis devant George
patient le dispositif Corum dont nous
avons toujours soutenu le principe ici
au Sénat est un bon outil pour créer
dans les collectivités en difficulté une
dynamique qui conduise à la
vertu il convient donc d'élargir ce
dispositif me semble-t-il et d'augmenter
les crédits qui sont alloués même si ces
derniers ont progressé afin que plus de
communes puissent en bénéficier
il est me semble-t-il regrettable que
l'enveloppe ne permette pas
d'accompagner plus les communes dans
cette trajectoire progressif de retour à
l'équilibre par exemple j'ai constaté
qu'à Mayotte une seule commune
aujourd'hui une seule commune Sada en
est bénéficiaire ça ne peut que
m'interroger car j'ai le souvenir de ma
rencontre avec les maires de maotte et
des difficulté j'en voie ici présent
devant moi quelle
rencontre voyons bien le bloc communal
dispose de moins en moins de marge de
manœuvre dans un contexte de plus en
plus tendu lié à une augmentation de
charges sans précédent il est donc
indispensable d'instaurer une véritable
autonomie financière et fiscale des
collectivité avec un panier de recette
clair en cohérence avec les compétences
et les charges des collectivités c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des propositions du
groupe de travail sur la
décentralisation mise en place l'an
dernier avec représentant de tous les
groupes politiques du Sénat pour
redonner aux élus locaux le pouvoir
d'agir je le dis devant les deux
rapporteurs Matthieu Darnaud et
Françoise Gattel sous l'autorité du
président de la commission des lois au
problème
financiers que je viens d'évoquer
s'ajoute des faiblesse en terme de
formation du personnel c'est un sujet
d'ailleurs qui m'a frappé dans ma
dernière visite en Guadeloupe et en
Martinique ce sujet a été fortement
porté par les élus tant en
administration de gestion qu'en
management ou en conduite de projet là
encore Françoise Gatel dans un rapport
le monte pour les communes polynésiennes
mais cette problématique il me paraît
qu'elle se retrouve dans les communes
des Trois Bassins géographiques il
convient dès lors de développer les
compétences au service de l'action
locale mais aussi d'améliorer les
dispositifs de soutien en matière
d'ingénierie et notamment d'ingénierie
de l'État je trouve intéressante la
proposition de nos collègues de la
commission des lois qui après s'être
rendu dans cas des territoires de
l'arcentillet Guadeloupe Martinique
Saint-Martin Saint-Bart ont souhaité que
l'assistance technique de l'État
notamment par l'entremise de l'Agence
française de développement puisse être
utilisé pour former oui former dans les
collectivités bénéficiaires personnel à
l'expertise technique nécessaire au
plein exercice de leur mission
judicieuse également la proposition de
généraliser au sein des collectivités
des plateformes d'appui en ingénierie
sur le modèle de celle mise en place en
Guyane avec les moyens humains et bien
sûr financiers nécessaires face à ces
constats au fond nous voulons un état
local accompagnateur et facilitateur
et non pas simplement
censeur pour cela il faut renforcer les
services de l'État dans les préfecture
leur redonner les moyens financiers
humains justifiés par la situation de
vos territoires et en fait rétablir ce
binôme maire préfet ou maire au
commissaire aux difficultés liées à la
perte d'autonomie financière et à la
faiblesse des compétences s'ajoute une
autre contrainte que vous connaissez
bien que nous connaissons tous
l'inflation normative face à celle-ci
les élus se sentent de plus en plus
paralysés dans leur capacité d'action
d'autant qu'elle a un impact financier
important sur nos collectivités je
rappelle le dernier chiffre du président
Lambert qui estime le coût au niveau
national des nouvelles normes en 2022 à
2 milliards et demi d'euros pour
l'ensemble de nos collectivités
territoriales de plus ces normes
nationales ne sont pas toujours adapté
aux contraintes particulières de vos
territoires je pense spécialement aux
normes en matière de construction et de
logement ce constat d'une adaptation
insuffisante des politiques publiques
aux spécificités de chaque territoire
ultramarin me paraît faire consensus
encore faut-il maintenant qu'on fasse
bouger du consensus il faut passer à
l'action l'inadaptation concerne aussi
bien la conduite des politiques publ que
le cadre normatif Stéphane artanau
l'avait rappelé avec Michelin jaqu dans
un rapport sur l'avenir institutionnel
des outremèes le besoin de
différenciation renforcé est affirmé par
tous les élus un exemple parmi tant
d'autres j reviens nous l'avons dit l'an
dernier l'AV la est un avis conforme en
autre maire alors que c'est un avis
simple dans l'Hexagone je pense que
cette question elle mérite vraiment
d'être posé et reposé encore cette année
dans cet esprit à la suite d'échange
avec les exécutifs locaux des
recommandations formulées au cours des
différents travaux de la délégation au
outremè je souhaite que soit déposé et
inscrit à l'ordre du jour du Sénat une
fois par an une proposition de loi
d'adaptation du droit des outres mè
c'est dans le projet que j'ai proposé
pour le trienna qui vient de s'ouvrir ce
rendez-vous annuel en plus de renforcer
les liens entre le Sénat et les
collectivités ultramarines permettrait
de mieux associer les élus de ces
territoires à l'élaboration de la loi et
obligerait les administrations des
différents ministères à être plus
réactives en matière en raison de son
institutionnalisation cette manière de
fabriquer la loi aurait en outre le
mérite de limiter le recours aux
ordonnances dont nous pensons qu'elle
aujourd'hui est un recours abusif
je souhaite que le
Sénat joue aussi un rôle central dans le
processus d'adaptation je viens l'évoqué
mais aussi de contrôle du gouvernement
sur la mise en place des décisions du
Comité interministériel des autres mères
en vu duquel chaque territoire a pu
transmettre les difficultés qu'elles
soient normativ qu'ell soi budgétaire ou
organisationnelle qu'il
rencontre dans le même esprit en réponse
à l'appel de Fort de France la
délégation aux outremers a préconisé
trois pistes de
réflexion première piste le statut C
constitutionnel mais qui ne saurait être
synonyme d'immobilis puisqu'il serait
accompagné d'une révolution de
méthode deè piste là où c'est souhaité
une modification des articles 73 et 74
de la Constitution afin de mettre à la
disposition des outromèes de nouveaux
outils en particulier pour les
collectivité demandeuse je parle bien
demandeuse trème piste un cadre
constitutionnel entièrement rénové
assimilable à une boîte à outils au sein
de laquelle chaque outromaire pourrait
choisir ce qui lui convient le mieux
dans le cadre d'une loi organique qui
serait donc faite sur
mesure ces scénarios nous les traiterons
lors d'une réunion spécifique du groupe
de travail institution qui se réunira le
13 déemb prochain je le dis en février
le Sénat rendra son rapport sur les
questions
institutionnelles sujet abordé par le
Président de la République dans sa
campagne électorale pour lequel il n'y a
pas eu de réunion
annoncé trans partisans ou transgoupe
politique mais au Sénat depuis
maintenant un an nous y travaillons et
nous rendrons notre rapport au mois de
février
prochain
dans cette période de multiples défis
votre rôle d'élu est fondamental car
vous incarnez je reprends le thème du
congrès de l'an dernier le pouvoir
d'agir ainsi le Sénat a voulu
repositionner les maires au cœur de nos
institutions en leur consacrant par
exemple un véritable statut de l'élu
permettant de mieux concilier vie
professionnelle personnelle et mandat et
surtout en vous protégeant davantage
protéger et je pense je ne sais pas si
salle que je pense à Blaise mornal maire
de petit canal en Guadeloupe qui a fait
l'objet d'une agression il y a peu et
bien la proposition de loi que nous
avons voté renforçant la sécurité des
élus locaux et la protection des maires
a été voté le mois dernier à l'unanimité
de notre assemblée c'est dire que nous
souhaitons vraiment vraiment protéger
ces élus deuxème temps fort et j'en ai
presque fini concerne l'enjeu de
l'eau dans plusieurs territoires
d'outremer les coupures d'eau les
infrastructure défectueuses les
sous-investissements les problèmes de
gouvernance les inégalités d'accès à
l'eau la dépendance au plus génère à la
fois la montée d'un sentiment
d'injustice au sein de la population de
fort mécontentement face à des
situations qui durent malgré des moyens
significatifs mis en œuvre
ces situations sont d'autant plus
difficiles à tolérer que les prix de
l'eau vont du simple au triple entre la
Réunion où elle est la moins chère et la
Guadeloupe où elle est la plus
chère je reprends le rapport du Conseil
économique social et environnemental
j'en parlais vendredi dernier avec le
président du
C l'eau toujours selon le rapport peut
également représenter jusqu'à 1/3 du
budget j'ai demandé à vérifier pour un
ménage modeste à
maotte je pense que tan Mohamed swalii
et Saï Omar wali pourront nous le
confier et le
confirmer ces difficultés concernant la
distribution de l'eau ne doivent pas
obérer un autre objectif prioritaire qui
doit nous mobiliser celui de la mise en
conformité des installations
d'assaainissement qui par leur véuseté
mettent en danger la santé humaine et
l'environnement la solidarité nationale
doit jouer je soutiens la proposition de
notre mission d'information qui
préconise pour davantage de justice
territoriale un soutien financier
spécifique aux offices de l'eau
ultraarin et la relance de la réflexion
sur la solidarité
interbassin
voilà comme vous pourrez le constater au
cours des échanges à venir le Sénat se
veut à votre écoute il a
particulièrement à cœur de représenter
vos collectivités dans le respect de vos
diversités et de votre histoire alors je
vous souhaite de fructueux débats et je
suis convaincu que cette journée doit
pouvoir répondre à vos attentes et puis
je vous invite à l'issue de vos travaux
à nous retrouver au pavillon de
l'Orangerie pour un moment de
convivialité ce sera quand même bien
mérité après cet après-midi de travail
et mon trop long discours mais je
voulais vous dire quelques chose
d'important
ici les communes des outrè c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est pas 212 parmi
35000 c'est quelque part le modèle
communal qui peut être un modèle de
vivre ensemble de proximité de relation
avec les citoyens et c'est me
semble-t-il ce dont nous avons le plus
besoin dans notre pays dans sa diversité
aujourd'hui très bon après-midi de
travail merci merci infiniment
merci merci infiniment monsieur le
Président Géral archer merci beaucoup
merci de l'applaudir encore
chaleureusement pour toute la
problématique oui c'est
important c'est c'est important
président Larcher vous avez bien sûr
donné des éléments de problématiqu mais
donner des dates outre le cocktail de
femme mais des dates fortes pour le pour
nos territoires alors bonjour et
bienvenue à vous tous pour cette 4e
rencontre organisée pour les maires des
outr-emèes depuis 2919 pardon à
l'initiative du président Gérard Larcher
qui nous fait bien sûr l'honneur de nous
recevoir encore une fois ici dans la
maison des collectivités locales votre
maison le Sénat mon nom est
Marie-Christine ponamalé je suis la
présidente du groupe du groupe méia
outrom 360 et très honoré bien sûr avec
beaucoup d'émotion de vous accompagner
de vous retrouver de nouveau cet
après-midi pour cette édition cet
événement est organisé par la délégation
sénatoriale des outres m présidée par le
nouveau président madame Micheline
Jacques sénateur de saint-bartelémie ici
présente quelques informations sur
l'organisation le président Gérard
Larché l'a rappelé il a souhaité encore
une fois pour cette séquence un dialogue
direct et sans filtre entre vous les
élus afin d'entendre vos préoccupations
vous les élus de terrain et de pouvoir
les faire remonter et également comme
vous l'avez rappelé président avec la
volonté d'associer toujours mieux les
maires et les élus ultramarins aux
travaux du Sénat vous avez énumérer un
certain nombre de dates il s'agit donc
d'un moment d'échange qui se veut le
plus interactif transversal et bien sûr
concis j'y reviendrai l'objectif est de
recueillir vos témoignages d'entendre
votre ressenti et vos propositions de ma
et d'élus l'organisation de cette
séquence est également en coordination
avec la MF qui a organisé le programme
de ce matin vous avez été très nombreux
à le suivre cette session si est
structurée en deux temps vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président une
première partie relative aux aspects
institutionnels qui porte sur l'avenir
de la commune et du maire une seconde
qui a axé sur les problématiques de
gestion locale la crise de l'eau ce
débat fait en particulier écho à la
situation de pénurie dramatique que
connaî Mayot mais également d'autres
territoires afin d'apporter l'éclairage
des élus sur les raisons et les les
conséquences de cette crise voilà pour
cette première partie et on va passer à
la première séquence et je vais
maintenant présenter nos intervenants
bien évidemment pour commencer nous
aurons les propos introductifs merci
d'accueillir chaleureusement le nouveau
président ou la nouvelle présidente
comme vous le souhaitez de la délégation
outrema madame la sénatrice Micheline
Jacques merci de l'accueillir chaleur
sénateur de
saint-bartéi à vos côté je fais les
présentations monsieur le sénateur
Mathieu dararnaud sénateur de l'Ardèche
premier vice-président du Sénat
président la délégation du bureau du
Sénat en charge du lien avec les
territoires et des consultation des élus
et des citoyens désolé pour la longueur
du titre membre de la délégation aux
autres maires rapporteur comme l'a dit
le président de la mission d'information
sur l'avenir de la commune et du
maire et à vos côtés madame la sénatrice
Catherine conc sénatrice de la Martinie
merci de l'applaudir chaleureusement
j'entends pas les voilà secrétaire du
Sénat membre de la délégation du bureau
du Sénat en charge du lien avec les
territoires et des consultations des
élus et des citoyens membres de la
délégation
outrè voilà vous pouvez encore
l'applaudir parce que je crois qu'on a
loupé des et Françoise Gatel sénateur
dil Villen président de la Délégation
aux collectivités territoriales à la
décentralisation merci aux premiers
intervenants vous pouvez les applaudir
et je vais inviter
euh le nouveau président de la
délégation autromèire à faire le propos
introductif merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues Mesdames et Messieurs les
maires et et les élus mesdames messieurs
euh je suis particulièrement heureuse de
vous accueillir cet après-midi au Sénat
en pour cette 4e rencontre dédié au
maire et élu d'outremire au nom des
membres de la délégation sénatoriale aux
outrem que j'ai l'honneur de présider
depuis peu je vous souhaite à la suite
du président Gérard Larché qui nous a
fait cette année encore l'honneur
d'ouvrir cette rencontre la bienvenue
dans la maison des collectivités
territoriales c'est-à-dire en réalité la
vôre je tiens aussi à remercier
l'Association des maires de France et
son président David lissnard avec
laquelle nous nous coordonnons pour
organiser cette belle journée des
outremèes nous avons à nouveau souhaité
nous mettre à votre écoute directement
et en filtre afin d'entendre vos
préoccupations et les faire remonter
priorité au dialogue au regard coisé et
au témoignages de terrain en organisant
ce rendez-vous la délégation est fidèle
à son ADN comme vous le savez notre
délégation est chargée d'une triple
mission une mission d'information du
Sénat sur les questions relatives aux
outremèes une mission de veille pour la
prise en compte des caractéristiques de
chaque collectivité et une mission
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
les concernant pour illustrer mon propos
je ne peux manquer de citer les
nombreuses études et recommandations
faites par un autre délégation au cours
de la précédente session en matière de
gestion des déchets de continuité
territoriale de foncier agricole et
d'aide à la parentalité nous avons été
force de propositions et dont le suom a
fait sien nombre d'entre elles en
matière de continuité territoriale tout
particulièrement ma collègue Catherine
Conconne qui a été la rapporteur de ces
travaux ne me contredira pas nous avons
obtenu des avancées significatives le
projet de loi de finances pour 2024
traduit l'effort budgétaire obtenu du
gouvernement naturellement cela ne
signifie pas qu'il ne nous faut pas
aller plus loin encore en matière de
politique du logement aussi notre
rapport de 2021 a très largement nourrri
les propositions du SIOM sur cet enjeu
si important pour nos territoires et vos
communes en particulier notre délégation
est de plus en plus attachée à donner
des suites concrètes à ces travaux y
compris sous la forme de proposition de
loi au cours des prochains mois
conformément au vœux exprimés par le
président Larcher nos travaux sur les
institutions nous conduisent à souhaiter
que l'État révolutionne ses méthodes et
son organisation un état profondément
déconcentré doté d'une agilité normative
outreemère et de plus en plus impératif
pour répondre à l'aspiration unanimement
partagée d'une coconstruction des
politiques publiques sur nos territoires
c'est afin d'approfondir cette voie ind
pensable que notre délégation a décidé
de lancer dans les prochaines semaines
une mission d'information sur les
modalités d'action et d'organisation de
l'État dans les outrèes deux temps forts
vont donc ritthmer cet après-midi un
premier portera sur l'avenir de la
commune et du maire je remercie très
sincèrement notre collègue Mathieu
Darnaud premier vice-président du Sénat
pour avoir accepté d'ouvrir cette cette
séquence nos collègues Catherine
canconne membre de la délégation et
secrétaire du Sénat et Françoise Gatel
présidente de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales apporteront
également leur regard sur ce sujet dans
une seconde séquence nous avons choisi
de débattre de la crise de l'eau outreem
la situation dramatique et inédite de
l'eau à Mayotte et dans toutes les têtes
et semble à peine conceva sur un
territoire de la République française
mais par-dà ces facteurs propres cette
crise après celle de la Guadeloupe qui
persiste interroge tous nos territoires
sur l'impérieuse nécessité de sécuriser
la question de l'eau sans laquelle aucun
développement harmonieux n'est possible
je remercie chaleureusement notre
collègue RV gilet rapporteur de la
récente mission d'information du Sénat
sur la gestion durable de l'eau de
prendre part à nos échange voici ce que
je souhaitais vous dire en brève
introduction avant de vous souhaiter à
tous d'excellents travaux et de
fructueux échanges je vous remercie
merci infiniment madame le Président
merci beaucoup alors place avec avec
votre collègue Mathieu Darnaud le
premier vice-président du Sénat qui a
fait un rapport sur la mission
d'information sur l'avenir de la commune
et du maire et qui va nous parler de
l'avenir de la commune et du maire c'est
à vous monsieur le
sénateur merci monsieur le Président du
du Sénat et je salue l'ensemble des
collègues
vice-président président de de
délégation et l'ensemble des collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs je n'oublie pas
celles et ceux qui sont à l'honneur à
savoir les les présidents d'association
de maires et l'ensemble des maires
ultramarins qui nous font le le plaisir
d'être parmi nous aujourd'hui au Sénat
alors effectivement nous avons commis il
y a de cela quelques semaines puisque
nous avons rendu au président du Sénat
ce rapport sur l'avenir de la la commune
au début du mois de de juillet dernier
la volonté était relativement claire sur
la portée de de ce rapport ce rapport
visait d'abord à à prendre en compte une
situation qui est finalement et c'est
vrai autant sur le territoire métropolit
que sur les territoires ultramarins un
mandat tout à fait singulier où
s'exprime malheureusement plusieurs
phénomènes le premier d'entre eux c'est
et le Président il a fait écho c'est le
phénomène de violence auquel se trouve
confronté l'ensemble des élus le second
il est peut-être aussi un peu singulier
parce que il tient
finalement d'une d'un particularisme sur
ce sur ce mandat avec la la mise en
place des des nouveaux exécutifs
communaux dans un temps où nous avons
été frappés par par la crise sanitaire
et puis tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui les élus que nous avons
auditionné autant élu ultramarin que
qu'élu métropolitain nous l'ONS tous dit
et finalement c'est le point commun à ce
rapport c'est les difficultés
aujourd'hui auxquelles vous êtes toutes
et tous confrontés difficultés qui
peuvent être d'ordre
financière difficultés qui sont liées
aussi à des rapports parfois complexes
avec avec l'État parfois un manque
d'agilité parfois un manque de de
réponse aux aspirations que que vous
portez ou encore difficultés que vous
pouvez rencontrer et notamment lorsque
nous sommes venus en Martinique et en
Guadeloupe avec le président du Senat
cela a été évoqué avec des
intercommunalités émergentes qui ont
parfois du mal à trouver un mode de
fonctionnement satisfaisant et qui
parfois mériterait à être revisité c'est
encore la le sujet de la sanctuirisation
finalement de la commune au-delà des des
22 communes que que vous représentez
aujourd'hui la commune c'est quelque
chose autant en métropole qu'en
outremaire qui est plus qu'un simple
échelon administratif plus que ce terme
qu'on a tendance à utiliser l'échelon de
base de la démocratie locale c'est aussi
le creuser des solidarités c'est ce lieu
où se tisse finalement L ensemble des
des solidarités finalement ce ce ce lieu
qui fait encore sens pour nos
concitoyens et on le voit même s'il
n'est pas épargné par le le le le
phénomène démocratique avec une
mobilisation de nos concitoyens qui
n'épargne pas la commune et qui se
trouve être en en baisse mais pour
autant cela reste l'échelon qui est
largement plébiscité par l'ensemble de
de nos concitoyens ultramarins comme
comme métropolitain alors pour se faire
et je vais essayer de faire œuvre de
concision parce que le temps qui m'est
imparti est relativement court mais je
sais que vous aurez à cœur d'avoir un
échange sur l'ensemble de ces sujets le
premier des thèmes que nous avons
souhaité aborder c'est finalement la
sanctuarisation de la commune avec un
versant constitutionnel il est deux
sujets qui sont pour nous essentiels le
premier de ces sujets c'est d'inscrire
dans la Constitution la clause de
compétence générale il faut à la commune
quelle qu'elle soit où qu'elle ce situe
et j'inclus dans mon propos les communes
de Polynésie et les communes de
Nouvelle-Calédonie d'ailleurs le fait
d'avoir un débat et de porter ce ce
sujet sur le versant constitutionnel
nous permettra peut-être d'avancer et je
me tourne vers mon collègue de de de
Nouvelle-Calédonie et ma collègue de mes
collègues de de Polynésie d'avancer sur
ce sujet essentiel qui est finalement le
statut de la commune sur ces territoires
et plus généralement avec l'ensemble des
autres territoires faire en sorte que
l'on reconnaisse la commune comme un
échelon tout à fait particulier un
échelon à part égard à ce que je viens
de dire le deuxième phénomène et alors
là aussi il est commun à l'ensemble des
territoires c'est le fait d'éiger en
principe suprême dans la Constitution la
le le principe suivant qui décide paye
ou qui paye décide parce que là c'est un
point commun que vous rencontrez chacune
et chacun dans vos territoires c'est que
très souvent que ce soit l'état
territorial ou l'État central vous
répondez en permanence jour après jour à
des injonctions et à des transferts de
charges qui sont parfois déguisés ou ou
apparents et malheureusement vous n'avez
plus au fil du temps les moyens de d'y
répondre et les moyens de faire en sorte
que les injonctions les souhaits de
l'État puisse trouver une concrétisation
sur vos territoires communal donc
inscrire ces deux principes qui pour
nous sont la
garantie de protection absolue de la
commune autant comme lieu particulier
cher au cœur de nos concitoyens mais
aussi comme cellule de base de la
démocratie je je je l'évoqué à l'instant
qui a cette agilité et qui permet de
répondre aux plus proches aux besoins de
l'ensemble de de nos concitoyens et je
crois que dans un temps particulièrement
compliqué auxquel se trouve confronté
notre notre pays mais beaucoup d'autres
pays la commune c'est aussi une des
réponses aux aspirations de nos
concitoyennes et de nos concitoyens le
deuxième sujet c'est le le rapport à
l'état aujourd'hui c'est une réalité
absolue et d'ailleurs nous avons voulu
un petit peu changer de paradigme nous
nous considérons que le temps est venu
de parler de territorialisation de
l'action publique comprendre par là le
fait que chaque territoire et le
président du Sénat il faisait référence
quand il parlait de la différenciation
territoriale chaque territoire a ses
propres atouts à à ses propres
faiblesses à ses propres ressources et
il est peut-être temps plutôt que
d'essayer de modéliser d'appliquer en
tout lieu et en tout point du territoire
un modèle de regarder finalement la
vérité à l'onne de chacun et des
territoire métropolitain ou ultramarin
je le dis parce que c'est important
c'est une nouvelle façon de penser le
territoire mais qui met au centre du jeu
encore un peu plus la commune et nous
avons largement plaidé pour que les
femmes et les hommes qui représentent
l'état sur nos territoires puissent
avoir cette capacité à lire le règlement
ou la norme on a beaucoup parlé de
l'inflation normative puisse le faire
avec une souplesse qui permette de
répondre aux spécificités de de nos
territoires on évoquait tout à l'heure
et chaque année votre serviteur dépose
par rapport à ce que disait le le
président sur la question des CDP NAF un
amendement pour qu'on aligne justement
le régime des communes ultra marines sur
euh le le régime métropolitain parce
qu'encore une fois il n'y a pas une une
vocation nécessaire une spécificité qui
plaide pour que on ait une différence
entre et j'en parle devant Vivianne mé
parce que c'est un sujet qu'elle porte
aussi avec force et conviction de de
différence convaincu que on doit avoir
une approche commune en revanche en
revanche et c'est là où où nous appelons
et nous plaidons pour une
différenciation pour une
territorialisation il est des sujets qui
ne se retrouvve pas ici en métropole
entre un territoire littoral ou un
territoire de montagne comme des sujets
qui peuvent être très différents selon
le bassin selon la particularité du
territoire dans lequel on se trouve que
l'on soit en Guyane à Mayotte ou ou ou
en Polynésie et puis renforcer l' encore
le président du sénalad CE couple maire
préfet ou maire Haut Commissaire
convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui pour répondre à ces
injonction de l'État vous avez besoin de
souplesse et d'agilité et là-dessus
c'est vraiment un point sur lequel nous
voulons pousser l'avantage au Sénat
parce que trop souvent quand on se
déplace sur vos territoire on entend ce
phénomène parfois de de lassitude d'une
réponse beaucoup trop longue d'un état
central qui peine à comprendre
l'impérieuse nécessité aller vite pour
vous parce que vite pour vous c'est
surtout mieux répondre et répondre en
temps et en heure aux exigences et aux
aspirations de vos concitoyens et cela
pour nous fait sens et ce que nous
voulons c'est là aussi a revisiter
quelque part ce fameux article 72 de de
de de la Constitution pardon excusez-moi
ainsi que le fait de
repenser l'intervention du préfet ou du
hautcomissaire pour justement avoir
cette cette plus grande agilité pour
nous c'est un des points centrals de ce
rapport parce que voyez-vous nous vivons
quelque chose de singulier jamais dans
la 5e République nous n'avons eu et
c'est vrai sur l'ensemble des
territoires de France autant de
démissions de maire nous arrivons à plus
de 30000 démissions d'élus locaux depuis
2020 depuis le début de ce mandat et
nous ne pouvons pas rester les bras
Ballan et parmi parmi les explications à
cette démotivation il y a ce sentiment
parfois d'être incompris parfois d'être
même déclassé selon le territoire dans
lequel on est considérant que l'État
veut encore une fois calquer en tout
point et en tout lieu du territoire un
modèle qui est pensé à Paris et ne voyez
pas Malis dans dans mon propos ou une
façon de de présenter les choses de
façon caricaturale mais trop souvent
parce qu'on ne comprend pas ce qui se
joue sur nos territoire et là-dessus
c'est vraiment un sujet qui nous tient à
cœur c'est redonner l'agilité nécessaire
en redonnant du souffle à ce couple
maire préfet ou maire au commissaire
pour que vous puissiez avoir des
réponses qui soient beaucoup plus
instantanées à à vos problématiques cela
bien sûr euh nous invite à réfléchir
autant sur le volet constitutionnel que
sur le le volet organique c'est ce que
nous prons nous proposons de faire avec
ce rapport mais je me permettrai de de
citer le le groupe de travail présidé
par le président du Sénat sur la
décentralisation et la déconcentration
parce qu'il n'y aura pas de de bonne
décentralisation s'il n'y a pas une
réelle déconcentration et ça me permet
de de rendre hommage au travail qui a
été fait par par Stéphane Artano et qui
a trouvé justement sa place dans le
groupe de travail sur sur la
décentralisation enfin dernier point
parce que je ne veux pas être trop long
euh il y a beaucoup beaucoup de sujets
que je n'aborderai pas dans le détail
aujourd'hui mais que vous retrouverez
facilement sur le site du Sénat avec la
présentation détaillée du rapport c'est
le statut de l'élu je préfère le terme
condition d'exercice du Monda local mais
j'insiste sur ce point pourquoi
j'insiste parce qu'on on voit aussi une
forme de de lassitude il y a 20 ans et
pour avoir replongé mon nez dans
certains rapports du Sénat final
finement il y a 20 ans on se posait la
même question et avec Françoise Gattel
nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur ce
sujet pour savoir quel était finalement
le le point principal qui invitait les
maires ou les élus à à se dire à mi
mandat je ne referai plus finalement un
nouveau mandat parce que je considère
que le temps est venu de passer la main
aujourd'hui ce qui est beaucoup plus
inquiétant c'est que les nouveaux
entrant dans la vie municipale
comprendre les femmes et les hommes qui
commencent leur premier mandat euh nous
disent avec la même lassitude je ne
referai pas euh de nouveaux mandats pour
l'ensemble des raisons que j'ai évoqué
la difficulté à agir la difficulté pour
l'élu d'être finalement cet acteur qui a
en main son destin considérant par la
même qu'il puisse euh répondre aux
aspirations de ces ces concitoyennes et
et de ces concitoyens et ça je crois que
c'est vraiment quelque chose euh à
prendre en compte alors on a essayé de
le faire sur l'ensemble des aspects à
commencer par la question de la
formation aux élus en en essayant de
revisiter un petit peu le le sujet
puisque nous étions passés de quelque
chose qui était peut-être un petit peu
trop large à quelque chose de trop
encadré convaincu aussi que les femmes
et les hommes qui intègrent la vie
municipal qui finalement ont à cœur de
faire bouger la vie de de leur commune
ont parfois du mal à se familiariser
avec l'immensité des normes des sigles
et de tout ce qui finalement nécessite
d'être pris en compte si on veut
comprendre le fonctionnement et la bonne
marche de la commune le deuxième sujet
le président y a répondu c'est la
question des violences aux élus et de la
difficulté aujourd'hui à mener à bien
son mandat lorsqu'on l'on a face à soi
avec insistance les réseaux sociaux qui
aujourd'hui permettent à chacune et à
chacun de nos concitoyens en temps réel
et parfois ex abrupto de venir commenter
la vie publique de façon assez violente
ou alors tout simplement sont confrontés
à une violence verbale ou physique nous
avons déposé un texte qui a été voté ici
même au Sénat qui permet de renforcer
l'échelle des peines en les calant sur
l'ensemble des personnes qui sont les
forces de sécurité et les personnes qui
sont dépositaires de de l'autorité
publique ou en renforçant la protection
fonctionnelle et juridictionnelle sur
laquelle nous avions déjà travaillé ici
même sur le texte engagement et
proximité au Sénat mais nous souhaitons
aller beaucoup plus loin parce que nous
voulons protéger de toutes les manières
possibles les élus les femmes et les
hommes qui s'engagent au au service de
leurs concitoyens et que vous
représentez aujourd'hui dans cette dans
cette salle c'est aussi la question tout
simplement des indemnités parce que nous
croyons qu'à un moment donné la
démocratie locale elle a un cout tout
simplement dans la capacité qu'elle
offre pour celles et ceux qui laissent
de côté leur activité professionnelle
parce qu'aujourd'hui on l'a vu on a
essayé de le mesurer être élu local
c'est beaucoup plus chronoph
que cela ne l'était il y a il y a 10 ou
20 ans et qu'il faut aussi pouvoir se
consacrer à son mandat et dire les
choses très clairement et je sais que il
y a cher Françoise Gatel un travail qui
est mené par la Délégation aux
collectivités parce qu'au Sénat on aime
bien dire les choses mais surtout on
aime bien avoir une copie qui est claire
qui ne souffre pas de contestation et
quand on dit les choses on aime bien
qu'elle soit exprimée clairement donc je
sais que la délégation fait un gros
travail sur sur ce sujet et puis
d'autres d'autres points que vous
retrouverez dans le rapport qui ont par
exemple vocation comme on a pu le faire
avec les sapeur pompier à faire en sorte
que vos années de mandat d'élu puissent
être pris en compte dans le calcul de de
vos retraites autant de de sujets qui
ont animé notre réflexion et qui
permettent aujourd'hui de présenter un
panel de propositions très claires très
concrètes qui ont vocation à faciliter
la vie votre quotidien et la vie que
vous menez ch ch jour pour servir
l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui
résident dans dans vos communes voilà en
quelques mots ce que je souhaitais dire
bien sûr nous sommes à votre disposition
pour répondre à à à toutes vos questions
je veux faire bien les propos qui ont
été tenus par le président Larcher à
l'instant président du Sénat je crois
que plus que jamais nous avons à cœur et
parfois même nous les prenons en modèle
nos 212 communes ultramarines c'est pour
nous quelque chose d'ESS essenti tout
simplement parce qu'elle nous renforce
dans l'idée que la commune c'est quelque
chose de différent c'est un échelon
différent c'est une strate qui est
différente et qui mérite qu'on y prête
une attention toute particulière dans un
pays qui est souvent aujourd'hui quel
que soit le territoire dans lequel on se
trouve malmené dans lequel nos
concitoyens ont besoin de réponse et
vous avez montré vous avez toujours
témoigné de l'attention permanente que
vous portez finalement à
l'épanouissement de nos concitoyens et
vous êtes finalement ce se rempart
contre les crises à chaque fois qu'il y
a une crise dans notre pays les femmes
et les hommes élus se retrouvent en
première ligne et je crois que
l'institution aujourd'hui que nous
représentons le le Sénat se doit aussi
de montrer combien elle est attentive à
votre quotidien combien elle aspire
finalement à sanctuariser cet esprit
communal qui est particulièrement
important essentiel dans la période dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons merci en
tout cas de de votre attention et puis
tout à fait disposé à à répondre à vos
interrogations sur ce sujet merci merci
infiniment monsieur le sénateur Mathieu
Darnaud vous avez démontré annoncé en
tout cas on a bien compris votre ardeur
et votre passion à défendre les élus et
la commune à travers ce rapport que je
vous rappelle le titre avis de tempête
sur la démocratie locale soignons le mal
des mares c'était le titre de ce rapport
et vous allez pouvoir poser des
questions dans un instant je vais passer
la parole à la sénatrice Catherine
concon qui va nous faire un témoignage
de terrain avec sa triple casquette si
je puis dire madame la sénatrice c'est à
VOUS bonjour à toutes et à tous
rassurez-vous la casquette que je
préfère c'est celle d'être avant tout
une
martiniicaaise impliquée citoyenne et
qui ne rechignera jamais à la tâche
quand mes compatriotes me sollicit de
par le territoire je tiens à saluer
singulièrement monsieur le Président du
Sénat cher Gérard Larcher j'ai
l'occasion déjà de vous le dire
plusieurs fois mais j'apprécie beaucoup
votre ouverture d'esprit et cette place
que vous donnez à nos pays régulièrement
dans les réflexions et dans les débats
qui ont cours au Sénat nos pays ne sont
pas la petite cerise sur le gâteau pour
vous nous sommes ingrédient à part
entière de ce gâteau républicain
institutionnel et vous n nous le
témoignez régulièrement je salue
également tous les collègues
parlementaires j'ai eu aperçu des
députés bien sûr les sénateurs qui sont
là très nombreux y compris à côté de moi
madame la présidente de la délégation
outreem fraîchement élue avec bonheur
cher Micheline jacqu qui vient de siibau
pays Saint-Bart et puis une attention
aussi pour tous ceux qui sont là je vais
les saluer singulièrement parce que je
crois en cette humanité très
particulière très singulière qu'il y a
derrière chacun de nos pays donc je
salue les
Guadeloupéens je salue les
Calédoniens je salue les guyanais
je salue les Maorais je salue les
Maorais je l'ai dit je salue
Saint-Pierre et miclon les saint-prois
c'est bien ça saint-pieret pardon
excuse-moi les Saint-Pierrois je salue
bien sûr les
Polynésiens je crois que j'ai fait le
tour de la planète et les walisiens
voilà et les walisiens
voilà et bien sûr je gardéis le plus
beau pour la fin les réunionnaires
voilà pour moi il est important que
derrière tous ces territoires on puisse
singulariser des peuples qui ont souvent
des histoires différentes des passés
différents mais qui représentent à eux
tout seul une une une une particularité
bien sûr une affection très particulière
pour mon pays la Martinique et tous les
martiniqu qui sont présents j'en ai vu
là de toutes les communes chelcher Gom
le carb avec mon ami
jean-claudeville j'ai vu le diamant j'ai
aperçu tris j'ai aperçu le Lamentin j'ai
aperçu Riviè pilote non franchement vous
êtes les bienvenus ici sachez que le
Sénat c'est la maison commune c'est la
maison de la République et tant qu'on
aura un président comme celui que nous
avons elle sera aussi votre maison je
sais pas ce qui nous attend demain
Président vous savez la la politique est
souvent grand carrefour d'inconnu et on
ne sait jamais ce qui nous attend demain
et comment pourrait pourrait demain
tourner les qualités de la République
liberté égalité fraternité ces trois
mots auxquels rajoutait volontiers mes
céser identité et c'est cette identité
que j'ai tenu à saluer dans l'ouverture
de mon propos nous avons ici en
particulier des élus municipaux et même
quand on a été sénateur comme moi ça a
été le cas on a aussi un passé d'élu
communal parce que c'est très rare que
quelqu'un qui ne soit pas passé par ce
temple de l'exercice démocratique ce
temple républicain qui la commune
devienne sénateur c'est un exercice
incroyable et extraordinaire de bonheur
en tout cas j'y a j'ai pratiqué cette
fonction pendant 17 ans on était en M
adjoint de la plus grosse ville de
Martinique et je peux vous dire ça étit
pour moi 17 ans de bonheur et ça été mon
plus beau euh moment euh d'élu mon plus
beau moment d'élu parce que on est au
carrefour des besoins et des
sollicitations de l'humain on s'occupe
de lui de la naissance à la mort on
s'occupe de lui à tous les moments les
les heureux comme les malheureux et on
s'occupe également de territoire que
l'on souhaite heureux en tentant de
l'aménager au mieux de lui porter de la
prospérité de la valeur ajoutée et c'est
un énorme chantier alors alors c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui la fonction
municipale est extrêmement secouée ça a
d'abord commencé avec cet étage de la
fusée qui a été
rajouté que sont les
EPCI les communautés de communes les
communautés d'aglo ou alors les
métropoles dans un certain nombre de
grands de grands centres comme en France
métropolitaine aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'entre vous Mair élu municipal doivent
peuent se sentir très dépossédés et très
éloignés de la réalité que leur
assigne leur compatriote leurs citoyens
aujourd'hui une compétence comme celle
des déchets est généralement dévolue à
la communauté de commune mais dès qu'il
y a le moindre papier gras sur vos
trottoir et bien c'est au ma qu'on en vu
et pourtant le maire n'a pas toujours
les manettes puisque ces budgets qui
sont maintenant confondus dans un gros
pot sont à part partagé y compris en
matière de responsabilité avec bien
d'autres le maire subit aussi une crise
le maire est bien sûr sa collectivité
une crise existentielle quel est
désormais son rôle au milieu de cet
amaigrissement progressif cet
amaigrissement progressif de ses
compétences de ses pouvoirs quel est son
rôle et pourtant la pression est encore
énorme il y a une crise d'autorité le
maire n'est plus le personnage sacralisé
comme l' était comme il était dans la
commune à l'époque missel met comme on
dit en créole de chez nous c'était un
personnage qu'on respectait aujourd'hui
il est plus àorté de gifle et
régulièrement on lui dit pas trop merci
mais on lui fait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de reproches souvent de manière
très violente au travers d'un exercice
qui est très aimé par les médias et que
personnellement je déteste les fameux
coups de gueule que vous devez savoir
qui sont lâchés comme ça sur les ones
sans modération sans réglage sans rien
du tout on peut tout dire et le
contraire de tout y compris au milieu de
1000 mensonges et derrière il est très
difficile de rectifier une
contevérité le maire est confronté aussi
à cette
vitesse qui est qui qui qui fait notre
quotidien Aujourd'hui celle qui nous est
assignée par les réseaux sociaux une
crise de l'immédiaté tout doit être fait
vite et rapidement ce qu'on pouvait
attendre un an maintenant et ben on
l'attend plus un jour c'est la même tout
de suite c'est maintenant et même quand
on a déposé un dossier si une semaine
après le boulon n'est pas fait et ben le
me n'est pas bon le ma est trop
lent on a bien sûr une crise de moyens
qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne peut pas ni
une crise de moyens et ces moyens ne
sont pas que financiers j'ai l'habitude
de dire que c'est peut-être le niveau
financier qui peut-être le plus facile à
régler avec quelques combats avec nos
présidents de commission de finances
respectif quelques bon lobbying au
niveau de l'État on peut attraper un
petit minon par-ci un petit minon par là
mais je parle surtout en particulier de
moyens quand je pense par exemple à
l'invasion de sargas dans ce certain
nombre de nos communes je pense à la
Martinique à la Guadeloupe à l'archipel
de Guadeloupe on a une représentante ici
de des Saintes et bien on a on est face
à une réalité difficile qui même lorsque
des budgets sont donnés une fois qu'on a
ramassé ces sgas c'est on en fait croire
surtout quand on vient nous dire
qu'elles sont extrêmement toxiques et
extrêmement polluer par toute espèce de
de produit y compris pour la Guadeloupe
et la Martinique de clord d'cone on a
aussi un combat à mener au quotidien
contre l'administration
française chaque délibération scrutée
chaque virgule on a parler tout à
l'heure de la CdP NAF mais pas que la
loi sur l'eau le moinre petit pont o il
faut mettre petit trou parce que il faut
une loi sur l'eau qui dure une mission
loi sur l'eau qui dure 1 an avec une
lecture parfois de laadal qui vient vous
dire oh non il y a un petit poisson très
rare qui et si vous mettez un petit
mètre cube de béton il va disparaître de
la planète pendant ce temps le pont est
en train de s'effondrer vos habitants ne
peuvent plus passer il y a euh cette cet
allègement de la de de l'administration
dans des pays qui sont soumis à
énormément de risque en dehors du risque
avalanche nous nous sommes soumis à tous
les risques on a des volcans la terre
tremble on a des risques inondation on a
des risquesraite côte et cetera et face
à nous une administration qui nous dit
tout le temps c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible et puis
j'ai parlé déjà des des EPCI et puis une
un problème de compétence qui est
souvent partagé alors Mathieu il me
semble que c'est Mathieu ou je sais qui
a ou le président d'ailleurs qui a parlé
de la fameuse clause de compétence
générale oui il faut que ce soit
sacralisé à aucun moment un maire ne
devrait être empêché lorsqu'il s'agit de
faire du bien à sa population il y a un
risque qui est là il y a une difficulté
qui est là il faut que le maire puisse
réagir bien sûr en tenant compte du
cadre légal mais qu'on ne lui assigne
pas en permanence un empilement de de de
procédure et bien qui met souvent en
péril la vie de ses administrés et la
vie de son territoire alors sachez
qu'ici au Sénat euh vous êtes très très
bien
an on a des combattants on a des
combattants de la première heure qui
siègent au Sénat et qui ne laisse rien
passer peut vous le dire ils sont combat
ils travaillent énormément contrairement
à la légende le Sénat c'est pas la
chambre où on gonfle j'aimerais bien de
temps en temps président que vous nous
accordiez 2 heures dans le planning
qu'on puisse se poser en peu moi je suis
arrivé ce matin je suis déjà au travail
on y sera encore la nuit c'est c'est une
chambre où on travaille énormément qu'
composé de beaucoup d'anciens maires
d'anciens ministres avec une exigence
très très haute et qui sort des combats
coqu qu'on qu'on aperçoit de l'autre
côté du côté des Invalides euh parce que
bon ici lorsque la loi arrive souvent en
2e rang et bien on a le temps de voir
venir les carences on a le temps de de
venir voir le désordre et pendant que ça
sétripe ailleurs et ben nous on est au
travail les commissions se réunissent il
y a énormément d'auditions et lors que
le Sénat livre en travail je peux vous
dire que c'est un travail abouti
rigoureux et fini on est très très loin
de la légende à laquelle on pourrait
croire je vais prendre le même temps que
Mathieu histoire histoire de
parité histoire de parité l'autre chose
que je l'autre chose que je c'était pour
taquiner Mathieu l'autre chose que je
voulais vous dire c'est que et je vais
conclure dessus plus que jamais nos pays
doivent pe-être au combat et c'est ce
que nous avons compris au Sénat il n'est
plus le temps où nous étions là en train
d'attendre que dispositif nous tombe sur
la tête et puis on commence à réagir on
n'est pas d'accord on va manifester dans
la rue on fait des pétitions ce temps-là
est terminé il faut absolument que nous
soyons en amont en veille de tout ce qui
pourrait nous arriver et c'est le cas en
ce moment du débat sur l'toin de mer il
n'est pas question pour nous de nous
renfermer et puis de dire touche pas
touche pas à l'OI de mer on en a besoin
certes c'est une taxe qui est utile à
nos finances mais il faut aussi qu'on se
pose la question de sa pertinence moi
j'ai un avis dessus on pourra en
débattre mais moi c'est une taxe que qui
me pose beaucoup de problèmes y compris
d'éthique et de philosophie par rapport
à des situations d'inéquité d'injustice
que je ressens et on pourrait en
discuter longtemps il est temps que nous
soyons en amont que nous ayons en
permanence le le sty Stot de notre
destin en main et que lorsqu'on entend
dire qu'il y aura une réforme dans l'air
et bien que dans les 3 4 mois qui
suivent nous soyons tous en mesure de
dire voilà ce que nous voulons voilà ce
que nous voulons c'est cette cette ce
réflexe qu'il faut qu'on ait ça passe
par beaucoup de formations qu'il
faudrait qu'on accepte parce que être
élu municipal du jour au lendemain ne
fait pas de nous un expert de la loi un
expert du règlement et un expert de de
de des des des différents tuyaux
complexes et compliqué de la République
il faut absolument miser pour que nos
élus soient en situation de leadership
permanent soit puissant et que l'on
puisse à tout moment pouvoir dire voilà
ce que nous voulons le temps de voilà ce
que N nous ne voulons pas est terminé il
faut inverser la terminologie et faire
de nous des acteurs des figures de prou
des gens qui sont en alternativ qui
précèdent les difficultés et qui soient
en permanence en mesure de d'être face-
à faceace avec la République non pas
dans une relation père enfant ça a
longtemps existé les enfants c'étaient
nous le père c'était l'ancien colon et
bien il faut que les choses s'inversent
et que nous soyons plus que jamais dans
une situation mature d'adulte à adulte
se regardant sans complexe sans dénis
les yeux dans les yeux pour avancer pour
le bien-être de nos populations parce
que comme disait un grand martiniqu les
meilleurs experts de nous-mêmes et ben
c'est nous-mêm tout merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup madame la sénatrice pour
cette cette défense également avec
hardardeur et passion j'en avais parlé
avec le le le sénateur à côté de vous
mais c'était sans c'était vous oubliez
hein avec votre vitamine venant du
volcan de la Martinique merci encore
pour cette défense des élus ils vont
pouvoir vous répondre elles et ils vont
pouvoir vous répondre dans un instant et
je cède la parole à madame le sénateur
d'il Villen Madame Françoise Gatel qui
travaille avec sa délégation et
également sur les outres Maes et
récemment elle a travaillé sur
l'intercommunalité en Polynésie c'est à
vous madame le sénateur merci beaucoup
monsieur le le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs chers collègues
députés représentants des associations
deslu notamment de la MF et vous tous
qui venez des outremes pour nous parler
de ce que vous êtes de ce que vous
voulez faire de vos ambitions et de ce
que vous attendez de nous alors moi je
ne suis pas d'outrem je suis de la
Bretagne skill Far West mais je vous
rassure dans cette terre de Bretagne il
y a des gens qui ont aussi beaucoup de
caractère et de détermination et je suis
heureuse de la partager de les partager
avec mesollègu alors peut-être en
complément vous avez vu qu'ici les gens
ont du caractère de la conviction et de
la détermination nous ne lâchons rien
comme on le dit souvent et le président
Larché est un excellent chef d'orchestre
d'une sorte de de tribu de gens qui
défendent avec
conviction le bloc local et notamment la
commune pourquoi parce que l'on dit
souvent que la commune c'est le dernier
kilomètre je pense que c'est le premier
kilomètre parce que c'est celui de la
proximité c'est celui où chaque jour ce
conjugue les valeurs de notre République
la liberté l'égalité la fraternité et
que la cohésion sociale dont nous avons
tant besoin c'est autour du maire que ça
se fabrique et je vous invite à lire
l'excellente édito ce matin dans Le
Figaro où on parle des Maes comme des
gardiens du temple et ce sont les
gardiens du temple de la République et
de la solidarité alors et vous allez
voir qu'au Sénat alors on a de la voix
on a de la conviction et que nous sommes
tous différents mais que nous partageons
le même discours et la même action parce
que vous verrez que les propos de nous
trois et de cher Micheline dont je salue
la récente é est brillante à la
présidence nous disons les mêmes choses
parfois avec nos mots et nos accents
mais c'est exactement la même chose et
très concrètement je voudrais rappeler
les très récents travaux du Sénat et
ceux que nous avons entamés le premier
c'est Mathieu dararnaud qui en a parlé
c'est la protection des élus il n'est
pas acceptable dans une république et
dans une démocratie que ceux qui s'engag
librement comme des citoyens
responsables pour aller porter l'intérêt
général servir leurs concitoyens soit
les victimes d'agression ou d'un baching
d'élu que l'on connaît donc nous avons
voté ici à la quasi unanimité une
proposition de loi sénatoriale sur la
protection des élus et au-delà de ce que
Mathieu Darnaud a expliqué comme item il
y a quelque chose de très important pour
lesquels les maires doivent se battre et
doivent être extrêmement vigilant c'est
le lien renforcé entre l'univers de la
justice et les élus locaux car il n'est
pas normal qu'un élu local un maire ne
sache pas ce qu'il advient des plaintes
qui est qui ont été déposé que parfois
elle n'était pas jusqu'ici prise en
compte et qu'il ne sacheent pas ce qu'il
advient sur son territoire de quelqu'un
qui n'est pas un élu mais un citoyen qui
pour une raison ou une autre a été
éloigné du territoire et soudainement un
habitant vient vous voir disant Monsieur
le Maire je comprends rien un tel qui
avait été éloigné du territoire il est
de retour et le maire ne le savait pas
donc il faut vraiment faire cette chaîne
de de sécurité pour que le maire puisse
exercer son vraimat le deuxième point
c'est ce qu'on appelle un statut de
l'élu alors le mot statut est gênant
parce que dans les maires il y a des
retraités il y a des salariés de l'état
des salariés de grandes ou petites
entreprises mais en tout cas ce que l'on
sait c'est que chaque citoyen dans notre
pays doit être à même de pouvoir
s'engager s'il a envie de s'engager pour
servir ses concitoyens mais que si le
mandat d'élu est un engagement civique
et ça n'est pas un métier il n'est plus
normal que les élus locaux soient
victimes et subissent des conséquences
financière négative alors même qu'ils
sont engagés pour servir donc nous
venons de rendre jeudi huit
propositions au nom de la délégation
mais je sais que le Sénat va approuve ça
h propositions pour permettre que si
vous vous engagez vous devz avoir une
indemnité qui vous permet de ne pas
perdre par rapport à votre situation
professionnelle antérieure donc il y a
huit propositions très précises je ne
vais pas les détaillé mais elles font
déjà les bonnes pages des des journaux
professionnels et nous travaillerons de
la même manière sur la retraite et un
certain nombre de choses donc une
indemnité qui doit être à la hauteur et
que l'État doit assumer pour une partie
parce que quand vous exercez votre
mandat de maire l'état civil
l'organisation des élections l'urbanise
ce sont des tâches de l'État et que si
on remplaçait l'ensemble des des élus
exécutif c'est-à-dire les maires et les
adjoints par des fonctionnaires le coût
pour l'État serait d'une autre nature et
la qualité de l'engagement ne serait pas
le même et puis nous entamons deux
autres volets de ce statut de l'élu le
second ce sera donc faciliter
l'engagement et faciliter l'exercice du
mandat c'est-à-dire que il doit être
plus facile d'avoir des autorisations
d'absence de se déplacer il doit être
plus facile de faire garder ses enfants
et quand on est étudiant on peut aussi
avoir envie de devenir élu local donc
faciliter
l'engagement faciliter j'en dirais un
mot tout à l'heure l'exercice du du
mandat c'est on devrait pouvoir être
maire sans avoir besoin à longueur de
journée de paracétamool parce que les
services de l'État vous donnent la
migraine non mais moi j'étais mare
j'étais maire et j'ai vécu ça je suis
rentrée dans un bureau toute seule il y
avait neu personnes je me suis dit mon
affaire doit être importante et on me
dit Madame le Maire alors votre idée
elle est excellente mais ça ne va pas
être possible euh et ben si il faut
trouver des solutions et j'en dirai un
mot tout à l'heure et ensuite il y a un
troisième volet qui est très important
c'est comment on encourage les gens à
s'engager sur un mandat de maire parce
que leur sortie sera sécurisé vous
connaissez comme moi des élus qui ont
pris des engagements en terme de
diminution de temps de travail qui ont
parfois je veux dire vécu des vies
personnelles difficiles à cause de leur
engagement et un dimanchoir parce que
les élections municipales c'est toujours
un dimanche soit parce que vous avez
décidé de vous arrêter le lundi matin
votre agenda év mais vous en connaissez
comme moi qui le dimanche soir ont été
avec surprise balayés il se retrouve le
lundi en difficulté pour retrouver un
emploi et se réinsérer il faut donc
qu'on traite ce volet là le 2uxè point
alors je salue tout particulièrement tu
ne m'en voudas pas parce que toi tu as
fait tu as fait le tour des outremèes je
voudrais saluer un salut particulier
pour la Polynésie parce que à la demande
du président du Sénat et notre collègue
Lana Toni nous avons fait il y a
quelques mois une mission en Polynésie
sur
l'intercommunalité et nous avons si nous
ne le savions pas découvert ce qu'est
l'éloignement par rapport à la métropole
ce qu'est l'insularité et la par
particularité de différence que vous
avez y compris au sein des outremerses y
compris au sein de la Polynésie que
l'égalité de droit se reconnaît par la
différence des moyens et je pense et le
président dans l'archer porte ça avec
beaucoup de conviction qu'il faut que
l'État nous écoute et que l'État aurait
moins d'ennui s'il écoutait s'il nous
permettait d'agir parce que je pense que
les élus locaux dès lors qu'on leur
laisse de la liberté ils savent faire
parce qu'ils sont aussi responsables
donc il est très important qu'on
permette de trouver des solutions qui
vous qui vous vont le mieux possible et
au sein des outremèes cela a été rappelé
vous avez aussi votre champ euh de
différent et nous nous défendons l'idée
nous étions tout à l'heure en réunion
avec nos amis de des Marquises nous
défendons l'idée qu'il faut avancer en
permettant en tout cas d'expérimenter ce
que peut-être je prends cet exemple des
Marquis mais vous en avez plein à PCI
d'archipel où l'on va donner des
capacités à AG en matière économique ou
touristique je reprends cet exemple
bientôt marquise il y aura un site
patrimonial de
l'UNESCO et donc il faut que ce
territoire a des capacités à agir en
matière de tourisme et d'économie et
puis dernier point sur ce sujet de
l'adaptation c'est la déconcentration
des services de l'État alors je suis
heureuse de saluer notre collègue agè
caniller qui est en face de moi qui avec
Eric kouche il y a quelques mois on fait
un rapport que tous les ministres devrai
lire matin midi et
soir parce que tout est dedans
c'est-à-dire on sait bien que tous les
diagnostics ont été fait c'està-dire
l'État ne doit plus être celui qui
contrôle quand vous avez déjà fait les
choses ou celui qui vous donne des
injonction depuis Paris que vous
habitiez en Martinique ou que vous soyez
élu dans ma Bretagne la déconcentration
c'est un état avec un préfet ou un haut
commissaire qui est au côté des élus
pour trouver des solutions et non pas
pour arriver comme tout effet vous dire
ça va pas être possible le contrôle de
l'égalité a dit non vous recommenz tout
donc il faut que les l'État soit au côté
des des élus et puis la simplification
alors moi je sais même plus prononcer ce
mot-l parce qu'apparemment on a du mal à
se faire comprendre n'est-ce pas
président les choses devraient être
simples il y a ici au Sénat dans
l'émicycle un éminent personnage qui
s'appelle Portalis ou qui s'appelait
Portalis il disait les lois sont faites
pour les hommes enfin les femmes aussi
mais à l'époque il disait pas et non pas
les hommes pour pour les lois c'estàd la
loi elle doit servir elle doit être
simple et elle doit être visible donc
nous nous avons proposé suite au rapport
que nous avons fait sur
l'intercommunalité dans les Marquises
qu'il y ait et c'est une proposition de
loi notre collègue Lana toon la mise en
ligne par l'état d'une version
consolidée à jour de toutes les
dispositions législativ que vous devriez
savoir par cœur mais qui sont éparpillés
dans des tas de codes et donc pour
appliquer la loi il faut que celle-ci
soit simple et qu'on la connaisse donc
voilà une proposition concrète que nous
soutiendrons de toute nos fores et puis
enfin le mot de la fin c'est celui de
subsidiarité alors ça paraît aussi
compliqué que simplification la
subsidiarité c'est très simple c'est
laisser faire le bon niveau et le bon
niveau on sait bien que c'est souvent
celui des élus locaux et je n'ose
imaginer je terminerai par ça une petite
anecdote en janvier dernier je vais
comme beaucoup d'entre vous à une
cérémonie des vœux j'arrive dans dans
cette dans cette petite commune et puis
il y avait trois dames quiarrêtaient pas
de raller sur leur m mais d'une manière
qui n'était pas sympa j'ai trouvé ça
moche parce que c'était la première
cérémonie de vœux de ce nouveau maire
élu en 2020 parce qu'à cause du virus
covid il a pas pu faire de cérémonie de
vœux et à un moment le maire me donne la
parole et j'ai dit mais ce que je crois
de tout mon cœur et que tout le monde
croit ici et que le président du Sénat
défend j'ai juste dit votre mère il
prend soin de vous tous les jours alors
vous pouvez ne pas avoir voté pour lui
vous vous pouvez trouver qu'il est mal
habillé que vraiment il est pas possible
voilà vous pouvez avoir un avis
différent mais respectez-le parce qu'il
prend soin de vous et si on ne prend pas
soin de nos élus locaux un jour personne
ne prendra soin de vous donc voilà ce
qu'ici au Sénat nous portons tous
ensemble avec détermination et nous
sommes sûrs de votre soutien et votre
surveillance positive au cas où nous
aurionss un moment de faiblesse mais ça
ne peut pas arriver parce que le
président veille au grain je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame le
sénateur Françoise
Gattel merci beaucoup en tout cas encore
une fois une défense des élus du terrain
vous l'avez compris tous les sénateurs
ici présents sénateurs et sénatrices
bien évidemment défendre votre statut
place maintenant aux questions pour des
raisons d'organisation je vais commencer
à demander au président d'association
des mairres s'ils veulent bien nous
faire un partage de d'expérience ou une
question que vous voudriez bien partager
oui non sinon je vais faire un choix
démocratique donc je vais décider toute
seule s'il n'y a pas de mains levée et
ensuite les élus et les sénateurs est-ce
qu'il y a un président d'association des
maires ou une présidente qui voudrait
prendre la parole ok non sinon je
demande si ou ça ah bien évidemment
madame Sonia Lagarde présidente de
l'Association des MRES de
Nouvelle-Calédonie je vais demander un
micro évidemment si quelqu'un ne l'a pas
qu'on la porte oui vous l'avez voilà ça
arrive merci de lui faire un accueil
s'il vous plaît le temps que le micro
arrive voilà merci
beaucoup bien merci merci beaucoup euh
j'été ravi d'entendre un certain nombre
de messages venant des sénateurs et qui
parlent des particularités
de
l'outreem et surtout des différences qui
existent en outrem entre les
départements et les
territoires ce matin j'ai eu
l'impression que on faisait un peu
l'amalgame
entre les départements alors que nous
sommes si différents
alors moi je suis en
Nouvelle-Calédonie je sais que le sujet
va arriver très bientôt
que les discussions sont engagées
qu'elles
sont compliquées le chemin sera long et
difficile mais ce que je voulais dire
ici puisque vous adressz au maire et
vous avez parlé effectivement tous d'une
même voix concernant ces maires qui
s'occupent qui sont des acteurs de
proximité qui sont proches de leurs
administrés alors à l'au de ces
discussions qui s'ouvrent moi je
voudrais simplement vous interpeller
c'est qu'il ne faut pas oublier les ma
dans ces
discussions j'insiste parce que
aujourd'hui il y a une confiscation des
discussion par un certain nombre d'élus
locaux et les maires qui sont on le dit
tous les jours des acteurs de proximité
et bien ils sont à nouveau les oubliés
de l'histoire et Dieu sait s'il y a des
choses à changer pour les communes le
code des communes de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie n'est pas le même que
le code des communes de la métropole euh
sur les compétences qui sont celles des
communes aujourd'hui et bien sur le
développement de nos territoires sur
l'urbanisme il va falloir changer les
chos pour donner excusez-moi un peu plus
de pouvoir au Mair qui aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement dépendants des règles
d'urbanisme des principes directeurs qui
sont votés par la Nouvelle-Calédonie et
en plus il y a aussi un code de
l'urbanisme avec les provinces c'est
toute la
complexité de ces compétences en
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui sont un véritable
millefeuille et où plus personne ne s'y
reconnaît et où les maires dans
l'aménagement de leur territoire et bien
sont suspendus à la fois à des règles
d'urbanisme de la Nouvelle-Calédonie les
principes directeur c'est normal mais
que les provinces est un code de
l'urbanisme qui s'impose à vous et que
quand vous avez un PUD il faut le voter
exactement de la même manière qu'à la
province il faut être bien avec le
président de la province ou la
présidente de la province pour que votre
PUD soit adopté et donc ça veut dire que
l'aménagement de votre teroire sur
lequel vous avez été élu bien évidemment
vous échappe donc voilà je voulais tout
simplement vous avertir que mais vous le
savez que il ne faudra pas laisser les
maires dans la rédaction d'un futur
statut et j'espère qu'on en aura un et
bien ne pas laisser les maires de côté
et donc si s'il fallait le dire ici au
Sénat puisque de toute façon vous aurez
bien
évidemment à discuter de ce futur statut
et des modifications institutionnelles
qui vont arriver très bientôt voilà
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame Sonia Lagarde
peut-être une réponse du côté de un avis
un mot oui monsieur le sénateur
oui pour pour dire tout simplement que
je je suis tout à fait d'accord avec les
propos qui viennent d'être tenu par par
Sonia Lagarde la présidente d'ailleurs
je crois qu'on avait eu un échange il y
a quelques temps sur les polices
municipales et et et les problématiques
auxquelles étaient parfois confrontés
les les maires je crois qu' en réalité
quand j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure le
rapport qu'on a commis sur l'avenir de
la commune j'ai pris à dessin le fait
que euh aujourd'hui la commune c'était
un modèle à part finalement dans dans
l'architecture institutionnelle
française à part tout simplement parce
que c'est la collectivité du quotidien
j'ai tendance à dire que c'est un peu la
patrie du quotidien la commune c'est
vraiment ce lieu encore une fois où euh
les euh les habitantes nos concitoyens
nos concitoyennes euh quels qu'ils soi
viennent vous voir pour pour tout toutes
les raisons et c'est ce qui font que
c'est ce qui fait pardon que nous nous
considérons que la clause de compétence
générale dans la Constitution Catherine
le disait tout à l'heure c'est cette
capacité qui sera laissée au maire de
pouvoir évoquer tous les sujets du
quotidien de nos concitoyens alors bien
évidemment que dans la question du
statut et des discussions
institutionnelles qui vont s'ouvrir la
commune doit nécessairement avoir une
place en cela quel est cet échelon de de
base cette capacité aussi à répondre et
à faire en sorte et et on le voit et et
souvent alors Catherine parlait tout à
l'heure des des des petits poissons dans
les rivières on peut dire exactement la
même chose en métropole avec avec les
grenouilles à ventre jaune et je ne sais
quel autre quelle autre espèce mais la
la réalité c'est que nous avons besoin
de cet ééchelon des communes pour
justement passer les crises passer les
difficultés quotidienne et faire en
sorte qu'il y ait toujours le fil de la
confiance qui puisse se nouer au à
échelon de de de de proximité et parce
que je crois que discuter d'un discuter
d'un statut mais c'est vrai quasiment
pour tous les territoire beaucoup de
territoires et on a vu dans dans le
groupe de travail sur sur la
décentralisation la nécessité qu'il y
avait à requestionner l'ensemble des
statuts de l'ensemble de de vos
territoires et bien évidemment que la
commune c'est une porte d'entrée je
dirais même que c'est pratiquement la
porte d'entrée sur ces sur ces sujetsl
parce qu'encore une fois on part de ce
qui intéresse en premier lieu nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens et et
c'est pour ça que je crois qu'il faut
redonner une place centrale à la commune
sur un versant constitutionnel mais
aussi en faisant en sorte que et vous
avez beaucoup parlé les uns et les
autres du lien avec l'État qu'on ait le
maximum d'agilité parce que trop souvent
aujourd'hui on est confrontés à des
niveaux d'intervention notamment de la
part de l'État qui ralentissent l'action
des maires et et on a parlé du rapport
vous parliez du rapport à la à la
province s'agissant des questions
d'urbanisme mais on pourrait dire
exactement la même chose en métropole ou
dans d'autres territoires et quand on
était avec le le président à Point à
Pitre on l'a évoqué la question du
rapport à l'intercommunalité sur ces
sujets donc il y a un moment donné il
faut repartir de la base c'est-à-dire de
la commune qui doit singulièrement sur
ces sujets du quotidien dont l'urbanisme
fait partie avoir les moyens d'action
qui permettent de répondre en temps et
en heure aux finalement aux aspirations
des habitants de et des habitants de de
de nos communes ça je crois que c'est
c'est vraiment fondamental et
malheureusement là encore le président
du Sénat le disait tout à l'heure on
assiste plutôt à une recentralisation et
nous on veut tordre le coup à ce
mouvement qui va selon nous dans le
mauvais sens parce que plus on
recentralisera plus on mettra
euh ce genre de sujet à un niveau
supracommunal plus on éloignera la
décision du concitoyen et le bon
interlocuteur la bonne interlocutrice
c'est le ou la mère je le dis et en tout
cas finalement je me tourne vers vers
Françoise vers vers Catherine et
Micheline c'est le point commun de
l'ensemble de nos travaux donc bien
évidemment selon moi et pour répondre
très directement et très franchement à
la question la commune doit forcément
avoir son mot à dire sur les évolutions
institutionnelles et statutaires merci
infiniment merci beaucoup oui vous
pouvez l'applaudir une autre
intervention dans la salle président
d'association des maires ou maire oui
monsieur le président d'association des
maires de Mayotte monsieur Mad madisouf
c'est à vous pour le micro le temps que
le micro arrive vous pouvez l'applaudir
en attendant l'encourager pour son
intervention merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrice euh monsieur
madisouf comme ça a été dit euh
président de l'association maire de
maotte et maire de pamanzi
Ben la commune c'est vrai
le principal personnages qu' l'incarne
le maire évolue dans un contexte
difficile fait de violence ou d'injure
ça été dit contre les élus des missions
de ma et surtout dans
l'Hexagone crise d'é voocation manque de
moyens tant humains que
financiers complexité de l'exercice du
mandat concurrence des interterc
euh je partage donc le principe point
évoqué dans ce
rapport notamment celui c'està-dire le
rapport de 12 juillet dernier intitulé
avis de tempête sur la démocratie
locale soignons le mal des mères donc
rendre aux communes la liberté et leur
avenir pard
assurer aux commande les moyens
financiers de leur
liberté par contre madame la sénatrice
nous les présidents
[Musique]
de association de autr maires de la
formant la délégation des autres maires
nous savons ce que nous voulons surtout
sur Leit de M nous nous sommes concertés
et nous avons décidé que nous nous ne
voulons pas que cette tro de MRE soit
euh comment dirais-je
euh doit évoluer bien sûr mais il il
doit pas disparaître parce que ça c'est
vraiment le lien ou la liberté des
collectivités pour
décider de ce que nous devons avoir pour
le développement de nos communes et j'en
passe comme vous le
savez ça a été dit dit tout à
l'heure la crise de l'eau qui passe à
maotte actuellement est
inédite certes les raisons est sont
multiples la la rareté des pluie mais
aussi il y a aussi une négligence aussi
vis-à-vis de l'État concernant tout ce
qui est investissement donc on n'a pas
trop anticipé pour qu'on puisse euh
comment euh ne pas avoir ce cette crise
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui vous le savez
aussi depuis l'année dernière nous
l'association de ma en compagnie de
maires de Mayot a été reçu ici par
Monsieur le Président Larcher que je
remercie nous avons
soulevé la violence que connaî
Mayotte certes l'état nous accompagne
nous avons eu une réponse ou des
réponsse mais qui n'a pas de perduré il
faudrait des réponses qui restent
pérenes à Mayotte
nous les maires qui sont venus ici on
est au Congrès mais nos pensées sont à
maillot vu de ce qui se passe là-bas
c'est pourquoi je demande à l'État au
Sénat aux élus que vous êtes de nous
accompagner ou de faire pression à
l'état à ce que tout ce qui se passe à
maotte cesse parce que nous n'en pouvons
plus maotte n'attire plus des
investisseurs à cause de C violence
maintenant la crise de
l'eau des enfants qui brûlent les
voitures les maisons on on est plus un
pays ou une île
attractive donc c'est ce que je voulais
dire au témoigner apporter un peu que
vous donnez n vous devez nous apporter
votre témoignage mais votre soutien au
vu de cette crise qui se passe à Mayot
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pour information
nousonsevenirau deuxème séquence donc si
quelqu'un veut rajouter sur la violence
ou sur une autre thématique madame le
sénateur c'est à vous oui merci merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le Président
peut-être en
écho à à votre propos le mot lassitude
des mères c'estd ils n'en veulent plus
comme l'on dit ils sont épuisés par un
certain nombre de choses les violences
en font partie mais surtout leur
incapacité à agir l'année dernière le
Congrès des Maires s'appelait le pouvoir
d'agir C c'est dire ce qui est
souhaitable et
nécessaire trop souvent n'est plus
possible parce que soit on n'a pas su
anticiper quand je dis
on je veux dire c'est une responsabilité
un peu collective et qui remonte à
quelques années sans doute quelques
quinquen je pense que parfois on agit en
pompier c'est-à-dire on arrive quand il
y a une crise qui est très forte et on
n'arrive pas toujours à éteindre de
manière satisfaisante le feu ou quand on
arrive à éteindre le feu continue à
couver parce que ce que vous dites
monsieur le Président c'est vrai partout
et c'est particulièrement vrai chez vous
c'est que les solutions doivent être
pérenes et elles doivent être travaillé
madame vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
avec les élus locaux et les élus locaux
c'est ceux qui savent et surtout ceux
qui sont comptables devant la population
parce que celui à qui on demande des
comptes c'est le maire et le maire ne
peut pas être le sous-traitant de l'État
chacun l'a dit le maire c'est un
partenaire comme un être vivant qui
marche sur deux jambes et l'État doit
être en accompagnement en stratégie et
en écoutant les élus locaux donc je
crois que ici au Sénat c'est ce que nous
portons et en même temps je pense que on
note parfois quelques progrès et
quelques bons apprentissages en
métropole pendant la crise covid il y
avait presque plus de règlement
figurez-vous parce que il y avait aucune
loi qui n'ait prévu de gérer la crise
covid personne pensait que ça arrivé et
donc les maires avec les préfets ils ont
inventé des solutions et soudainement
l'impression que tout le monde enfin en
même temps il était très stressé mais on
respirait parce qu'il fallait inventer
des choses et qu'à un moment les
fonctionnaires de l'État comme les
locaux parce que ils voulaient bien agir
ils ont inventé des solutions et que je
pense qu'il faut redonner cette capacité
aux élus locaux mais ne pas les laisser
tout seul et sincèrement je pense que
c'est dans une relation de confiance et
de
responsabilité en identifiant les sujets
je pense qu'à Mayot les sujets sont
particulièrement identifiés que
aujourd'hui le chemin c'est un chemin
qui est long mais on ne doit jamais
faiblir sur le chemin et les élus locaux
que vous êtes portent la responsabilité
la dignité de la République dans les
solution au
problème merci de vos de vos
témoignages merci beaucoup merci
infiniment alors oui il y a une dernière
intervention pour clôturer cette
séquence sur les communes et ensuite
nous allons passer la deuxième séquence
puisqu'on court un peu sur le temps
voilà le micro arrive n'hésitez pas je
vous vois pas d'ici euh à décliner votre
identité s'il vous plaît voilà merci
beaucoupoui bonjour à tous je suis
Madame Carpin Jacqueline conseillère
municipale à la commune de Saint-Paul
l'île de la Réunion voilà alors moi je
veux porter un témoignage vous avez dit
des choses qui m'ont vraiment touché et
qui ont percuté dans mon quotidien par
rapport à la violence
euh le chômage c'est quelque chose qui
qui qui est très bien répandu on a à
faaire à des citoyens qui ne comprennent
pas toujours ce ce non partage des
contrats et ce nom partage des
logements et donc qui cristallise sur un
élu cette cette souffrance dans laquelle
ils sont et donc moi je veux témoigner
de termes qui m'ont été adressé et un
autre élu aussi
et qui a porté plainte et et au lieu que
ça est une fonction apaisante au
contraire ça alimenté comme si dirait un
élu devait se devait de recevoir des
mots de des comment dire des
oui des mots enfin je sais même pas
comment qualifier ces mots comme si ça
fait partie de notre rôle et de
d'encaisser et de se taire et donc le
fait que nous ayons porté plainte ça a
été quelque chose qui a allumé un peu
comme une poudrière
et moi j'ai reçu des des des textos sur
lesquels on me disait
ben continuez de vous engresser avec
l'argent de l'État continuez à vous mais
il faut vivre ces choseslà nous sommes
des élus des hommes et des femmes
parfois des femmes qui vivent seules et
qui ne se sentent pas en sécurité alors
euh je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
qu'est-ce qui peut euh être répondu à à
mes à mon interrogation mais c'est
vraiment un vécu qui est euh euh
douloureux parfois parce que comme vous
l'avez précisé à un moment donné euh on
se dit ben mince alors si j'avais su je
serais pas venu voilà donc euh parce que
on fait quelque chose c'est un rôle
noble quand même d'être un un
représentant de la République c'est ce
qu'on nous a dit au début quand on est
arrivé
euh on s'est dit bon sang mais on avait
pas signé pour ça on est représentant de
la République mais c'est quelque chose
ça donc on le prend vraiment à cœur
cette fonction on aime ce qu'on fait
parce que comme je vous dis cette
noblesse elle est aussi elle nous est
aussi renvoyé quand ça se passe bien
quand quelqu'un a eu son dossier qui a
été traité quand quelqu'un a eu un
contrat qui lui a été attribué et qu'on
a des gens qui sont content donc quelque
part on se dit ça vaut le coup ça vaut
le coup on y va on repart demain matin
mais quand on a affaire à ce genre d'un
de comportement qui vous touche même pas
comment vous pouvez répondre quand vous
êtes atteint dans votre condition de
femme qu'est-ce que vous pouvez changer
à votre condition de femme à votre
couleur à votre
catégorie je suis une indienne voilà
donc les les malbars voilà ce que on
peut nous Balan lancer ou alors le les
les Cafres les Africains qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez répondre à ça il y a rien de
plus euh vraiment touchant parce que ça
vient dans votre inside ça vient à
l'intérieur et ça vous met dans un état
de vraiment vous vous vous êtes vous
êtes mal voilà et et vous êtes
malheureux donc moi je je j'ai envie de
savoir parce que au-delà de de nous
présenter de de la conscience avec
laquelle vous prenez euh soin de de nous
dire les choses concernant la violence
qu'est-ce que vous allez travailler
dessus pour que voilà parce que quand
moi moi mon camarade quand il se fait
traiter de toutes sortes de noms sur sa
condition d'homme j'ai mal j'ai mal en
tant qu'être humain juste ça et donc je
me dis il faut que j'arrête parfait je
dis on voulait vous remercier Madame en
tout cas on a bien compris votre
témoignage sur la violence bravo et je
vais laisser madame la sénatrice
Catherine con vous répondre je vois que
les mains se lèvent donc on va essayer
d'accélérer madame la sédatrice c'est à
vous merci pour ce témoignage touschant
de notre collègue de la Réunion euh vous
savez c'est quoi le problème l'école
n'éduque pas et ne fabrique pas de
citoyens on arrive je reçois parfois des
élèves de terminal ici au Sénat qui
viennent visiter parce qu'ils sont en
classe d'étude et cetera déplacement
avec leurs enseignants et quand ils
arrivent la première question que je
pose dans la cour de jonction quand je
les rencontre est-ce que vous savez
c'est quoi le Sénat dans 99 % des cas
j'ai dooit à non autrement dit on arrive
à 16 17 ans après être passé près de 15
ans à
l'école et puis euh on se rend compte
que ils viennent visiter le Sénat mais
ils savent pas c'est quoi je leur
demande pas qu'il m'explique c'était
quoi la vie de Marie de M ça c'est une
are histoire l'ancienne occupante des
lieux mais au moins me répondre que le
Sénat c'est une des chambres du
Parlement quand je leur dis qu'on vote
des lois ils savent pas comment on
fabrique la loi il y a une absence
totale de formation sérieuse de nos
gamins à l'école puisque ce sont les
citoyens de demain quant à cette
citoyenneté active que nous vivons
autrement dit ne connaissent personne ou
très peu de gens connaissent les limites
d'un élu ce qu'il y a derrière un élu
comment se constitue un budget municipal
on a l'impression que le meilleur peut
tout suffit qu'il fasse un chè il fait
le mur l'école la MGC enfin bref tout
est possible et personne ne sait d'où
viennent les recettes et comment tout
cela se fait est-ce qui est possible on
ne sait même pas quelle est la
différence de compétence entre le
Conseil Territorial la route
départementale la route municipale la
route privée le lotissement privé on ne
sait pas et j'ai eu deux ou trois
discussions assez fermes avec la
rectrice de martinque récemment en lui
disant que si on voulait baisser la
violence si on voulait avoir une
citoyenneté plus épanouie moins
conflictuelle que l'école portait sa
part de
responsabilité parce que bon à l'école à
l'époque on avait instruction civique et
tout on me dit oui maintenant il y a un
truc là avec un sigle je sais pas quoi
mais même les enseignants me disent
c'est de la foutise ce sont les profs
d'histoir et Goo qui font ça quand ils
ont le temps et que parfois une année
scolaire passe ce qu'on a même expliqué
un enfant c'est quoi un maire c'est quoi
une mairie alors après je ne vous dis
même pas l'adulte qui est déjà adulte
non il se nourrit de de de tout ce qui
se fait de plus négatif sur les réseaux
sociaux et nous élu on doit passer un
temps fou à rectifier non c'est pas vrai
non c'est pas possible combien de fois
on a dit qu'un sénateur gagnait 12000 €
que ça m'a et bien sûr avec tout ce
qu'il y a comme effvective avec allez
vous AES vous gagnez beaucoup d'argent
et cetera et que je je suis obligé
jusqu'à présent de me promener avec ma
feuille de rémunération et dès que je
reçois ce genre d'attaque je la montre
et les gens me disent ah bon tout ça
pour ça je ne parle même pas de ma
j'étais ma adjoint 2è ma adjoint d'une
grosse ville celle de fort-de-fance en
charge de la sécurité où toutes les
nuits il fallait que j'aille sur le
terrain contre les voleurs les
prostitués j' passé des meilleurs
résultat j'avais 700 € par mois et
pareil lorsque je montrais ma fiche de
rémunération les gens me disaient ah bon
ça seulement pour faire tout ça mais à
quel moment on instruit les citoyens sur
ça sur le rôle de l'élu on a face à nous
des gens qui peuvent tout pour vous sans
exception alors la seule parade qu'il y
a c'est communiquer communiquer beaucoup
dire la vérité dire la vérité même sur
les choses qui peuvent paraître pudiques
exemple notre rémunération moi je la je
la je la montre sans aucun problème dire
notre quotidien moi j'affiche mon agenda
chaque semaine voilà ce que je fais vous
voyez il y a pas une minute où c'est
marqué ronflement au Sénat voilà donc
euh euh on
tue on a les huissiers qui nous
rappellent à l'ordre donc on a une un
effort de transparence et de
communication énorme à faire pour
rétablir mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
l'éducation nationale doit rentrer dans
une logique de formation du citoyen
savoir que 2 + 2 sont font quatre c'est
bien et encore allez on a vu la grille
des niveaux récemment il y en a encore
il y en a beaucoup qui doivent trouver
que ça fait 5 mais en tout cas on ne
peut pas laisser sortir de terminal des
des jeunes le citoyens de d'aujourd'hui
et de demain sans même qu'il sache c'est
quoi l'Assemblée nationale c'est quoi un
procureur c'est comment fonctionne la
justice ce n'est pas possible et on va
être face à cette armée d'ignorant entre
guillemets en permanence et qui vont
attendre de nous tout et le contraire de
tout avec l'agressivité qui ira avec et
cetera donc l'éducation nationale pour
moi c'est un maillon important de la
formation du citoyen merci beaucoup
madame la sénatrice l'éducation
nationale comme le rappelit également la
sénatrice Annique Girardin qui faisait
allusion aux médias donc évidemment nous
avons tous un rôle à jouer vous avez
raison madame la sénatrice et et donc je
vais allez encore une
intervention présid excusez-moi
excusez-moi mais nous avons 45 minutes
de retard sur le temps et euh PARG pour
ns pour nos nos amis de de Mayotte et
des autres collectivité qui vraiment
souffre des problématiques de l'eau il
faudrait que l'on puisse passer à la
deuxème table roundond la présidente
merci d'applaudir les intervenants de
cette première séquence la présidente a
donné le là merci sénateur merci madame
la sénatrice les sénatrice merci
beaucoup place à la deème table ronde
sur les problématiques de gestion locale
et et la crise de l'eau en premier le
choix excusez-moi s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît nous allons passer à la
deuxième séquence le choix s'est porté
sur une problématique d'actualité
transversale et particulièrement aigu
vous le savez celle de la crise de l'eau
qui touche bon nombre de territoires pas
seulement C mayayot cette question a
fait l'objet de nombreux travaux du C en
l'occurrence récemment le Sénat a fait
l'objet à élaboré un rapport
d'information sur la gestion durable de
l'eau intitulé l'urgence d'agir pour nos
usages nos territoires et notre en
ronnement du 12 juillet
2023 le rapporteur RV gilet a va exposer
les conclusions de cette mission et nous
allons avoir les deux sénateurs de
Mayotte qui vont apporter leurs
témoignage mais tous les territoires
Guadeloupe Martinique Saint-Martin
Polynésie la Réunion bien d'autres sont
concerné et on pourra faire circuler la
parole bien évidemment alors comme tout
le monde a pris place mais sans me
concerter et on a un petit problème de
chaise voilà donc si vous voulez bien
décaler comme ça ça fera un peu de vie
ou alors on laisse comme ça c'est c'est
pas grave on va faire mais je vous
demande votre attention s'il vous plaît
on passe à la deuxème séquence donc nous
allons merci d'accueillir
chaleureusement je vais préciser les
intervenants Monsieur Hervé Gillet
sénateur de Gironde B je vous entends
pas applaudir rapporteur de la mission
d'information du Sénat sur la gestion de
l'eau durable dont le président était
Rémi pointerau et ensuite à vos côté
bien évidemment ils ont pris place le
sénateur tan Mohamed soelli et le
sénateur Saïd Omar au Ali merci de leur
faire un bon accueil voilà donc je vais
donner la parole à Monsieur le Sénateur
Hervé gilet c'est à vous bien merci
beaucoup je suis très heureux et très
honoré donc d'intervenir dans le cadre
de cette journée au côté bien sûr de de
mes collègues pour vous présenter
effectivement nos travaux concernant
donc cette mission d'information alors
une mission d'information c'est décidé
soit par une commission permanente ou
par des groupes politiques ce fut le cas
pour mon groupe socialiste écologique et
républicain mais vous savez au Sénat
elles sont composées d'une manière
transpartisane il faut toujours avoir
cet esprit effectivement en tête et les
travaux que nous avons pu mener ont
essayé de prendre en considération
l'ensemble des propositions et des
remarques pour essayer d'avoir un
rapport qui soit le plus productif
possible cette mission elle a travaillé
donc de février à juillet 2023 c'est là
où on a remis notre rapport ce fut une
mission particulièrement lourde
puisqu'on a mené 66 auditions quatre
déplacements alors certes on avavait pas
de de sénateur ultramarin mais dès le
début il a été décidé bien sûr de
s'intéresser au problème de l'eau dans
les outresmers même si les régimes
hydrique sont très différents de la
France hexagonale et et au niveau des
différents territoires les
problématiques spécifiques il fallait
donc les souligné sur sur ces sujets-là
notre mission portée donc sur l'ensemble
des aspects de la politique tique de
l'eau c'estàd autant le ce qu'on appelle
le grand cycle de l'eau et sur le petit
cycle mais concernant les outr-merses
nous nous sommes concentrés sur les
questions liées au petit
cycleapovisionnement de la population en
eau potable ou encore toutes les
problématiques d'assainissement qui pèse
assez lourdement sur les systèmes nous
avons tenu dans ce cadre là donc une
table ronde le 16 mai dernier en
visioconférence avec les offic de l'eau
de Guadeloupe de Martinique de Guyane et
de la Réunion et puis bien sûr la
Direction de l'Environnement de
l'Aménagement et du Logement de
Mayotte plusieurs constats sont partagés
malheureusement l'approvisionnement en
eau potable est encore insuffisant dans
de nombreux territoires en particulier à
Mayotte et en Guadeloupe des tours d'eau
doivent être organisés ce qui est est
assez inacceptable aujourd'hui au 21e
siècle on a donc un un véritable défi à
la fois de production d'eau potable bien
sûr à Mayotte à partir par exemple de
solutions alternatives mais très
coûteuses comme la désalanisation mais
aussi de rénovation voire de
construction de réseau de distribution
et on aura l'occasion d'y revenir on
fait donc face à un enjeu majeur de
gouvernance et
d'investissement les territoires où
l'approvisionnement en eau est
défaillant n'ont pas les moyens de
financer des travaux qui sont absolument
colossaux et il faudra forcément
s'interroger sur la conduite à tenir
pour accompagner l'ensemble des
collectivités pour retrouver un système
qui soit effectivement plus en plus en
équilibre il faut donc que la solidarité
nationale joue à plein et au demeurant
on ne peut qu' constater que la pauvreté
d'un certain nombre de consommateurs
rend parfois difficile parfois même
impossible de leur demander une part
accrue de financement par l'augmentation
des factures d'eau dont une partie ne
sont d'ailleurs pas toujours recouvrer
et il faut également faire ce constat ce
qui peut parfois se comprendre et quand
on a de l'eau de manière de discontinue
quand on a une offre de service qui est
dégradée effectivement on peut concevoir
qu'il y a moins de légitimité de devoir
payer pour un service qui est
relativement mal assuré de sur croix se
pose des problèmes de qualité de zoau et
de la qualité des sources
d'approvisionnement donc aux Antilles la
présence de de chlore d'con renchérit
les cûps de traitement en Guyane c'est
le mercure dû à l'orpaillage clandestin
qui pose des problèmes de manière
presque endémique ce sont aussi les
rogets organiques dans l'environnement
lié à une mauvaise maîtrise de
l'assaainissement qui dégrade la qualité
des EOS capté pour approvisionner donc
les habitants enfin la diversité des
territoires ultramarins ça a été
souligné lors du précédent échange de
leur problématique impose de faire
preuve de souplesse et d'ingéniosité de
mobiliser toute la palette des outils
existants et notamment sur le plan
technologique alors partant de ces
constats quel pourrait être les les
pistes de main les pistes d'amélioration
et
d'accompagnement la piste financière
bien sûr elle est évidente elle figure
dans le plan haut en 53 mesures du
gouvernement puisque la mesure 40
prévoit de mobiliser 35 millions d'euros
par an en plus pour la politique de
l'eau dans les autresomers au titre de
la solidarité interbassin mais ça il
faut quand même le le souligner c'est
une proposition que nous soutenons bien
sûr et qui figure aussi dans les
préconisations de notre reppport c'est
la proposition 42 cette solidarité
interbassin au bénéfice des territoires
ultramarins va connaître un début de
mise en œuvre en 2024 à travers la
hausse de la contribution des agences de
l'eau à l'Office français de la
biodiversité l'ofb de 15 millions
d'euros en 2024 et 35 millions d'euros
en 2025 d'après les les documents
budgétaires qui accompagnent le projet
doit de finance à tiellement en
discussion et on y regardera finement
d'un peu plus près pour bien vérifier
ces inscriptions budgétaires au
demeurant dans le cadre du plan de
relance l'ofb disposé de 85 millions
d'euros sur les tro année 2021 2023 dont
47 pour financer des projets portant sur
l'eau et l'assaainissement en outreem
mais au-delà des financements il faut
aussi une ingénierie pour porter des
projets et les faire avancer localement
c'est-à-dire planifier les travaux
passer les marchés les suivre et ensuite
mettre en service les infrastructures et
et ce sujet-l est un sujet
particulièrement important je voudrais
le souligner à l'heure actuelle sur le
territoire national de toute manière il
y a déjà des problèmes de
compétenenceces et de mobilisation des
compétences les collec les collectivités
font face à certaines difficultés pour
répondre au cahier des charges qui sont
parfois exigés par l'État par les
procédures d'État parce que les cabinets
conseil sont déjà en crise de
recrutement et de compétences et pour
consolider les cabinets conseil il faut
avoir de la lisibilité pour pouvoir
faire les embauches et et avoir les
compétences qui sont nécessaires et et
ce sujet-là sur les territoires
d'outremè est un sujet qui doit nous
intéresser particulièrement parce que il
ne s'agit pas forcément que d'avoir des
enveloppes financières à disposition il
faut bien sûr avoir les moyen aussi
humains d'ingénierie d'accompagnement
pour permettre la mise en œuvre et faire
en sorte que cette mise en œuvre
respecte un calendrier qui permettent
petit à petit de relever les modèles et
de les rendre plus efficaces et c'est un
sujet qui est vrai très très important
donc nos auditions ont montré que cette
ingénierie n'était donc pas facile à
trouver y compris en passant des marchés
d'assistance à maîtrise d'ouvrage et
parfois les bureaux d'études qui pourrai
intervenir n'existent donc tout
simplement pas ou ne répondent pas et
donc la mesure numéro 30 du plan haut du
gouvernement prévoit ainsi de lancer 10
projets de solution fondés notamment sur
la nature portant sur le petit cycle le
grand cycle mais comment faire quand on
a personne pour concevoir et suivre ses
projets donc N nous pensons qu'il va
falloir sans doute essayer de militer
pour mobiliser une force d'appui au
niveau national d'appui au territoire
d'outrem pour les accompagner dans les
meilleures conditions et mobiliser
toutes les compétences utiles et
nécessaires pour pouvoir avancer
correctement sur ces projet donc cette
notion de mutualisation de mise à
disposition des compétences est
particulièrement importante on va y
travailler avec vous parce que nous
pensons que c'est quand même une
démarche absolument essentielle enfin se
pose la question de la gouvernance de
la loi a prévu de transférer les
compétences haut et assaainissement bien
sûr aux EPCI vous savez que ce sujet
fait débat ce qui permettra de mettre en
œuvre les mutualisations nécessaires euh
alors quand on dit fait débat au Sénat
je peux vous assurer qu'il fait débat
hein il fait Desbat donc il y a la
perspective de 2026 par rapport à ça
ceci étant bon il faut quand même aussi
avoir la lucidité de voir que les petits
systèmes d'eau et d'assaainissement ont
parfois les plus de difficultés à
pouvoir s'adapter aujourd'hui aux nouvel
contrainte et donc par un accompagnement
bienveillant le faire de renforcer les
moyens et de mutualiser peut permettre
d'avoir un niveau de réponse qui soit
effectivement plus efficace pour
conclure cette brève présentation parce
que le but du jeu c'est aussi au travers
des différentes interventions aussi de
nos collègues et de la salle de répondre
à à des questions nous ne parlons pas
nous ne partons pas d'une feuille vierge
bien évidemment le plan haut d'homme
avait été lancé en 2016 et doit se
déployer jusqu'en 2026 pour mettre à
niveau les réseaux les plus défaillants
mais les crédits ont été sous-consommés
et ça revient à ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure en terme de
résonance c'est une question
fondamentale il faut donc accélérer
c'est ce que disait d'ailleurs le
rapport de 2022 du Conseil économique et
social environnemental le cés en
particulier pour la Guadeloupe la Guyane
et Mayotte bien sûr qui vit une
situation particulièrement lourde et
dramatique et dans ce dernier territoire
la combinaison de risque accru de
sécheresse et l'augmentation de la
population rend nécessaire
l'investissement d'une part dans des
capacités supplémentaires de
désalinisation et d'autre part dans la
fiabilisation des réseaux de
distribution les taux de perte vous
savez sont particulièrement conséquents
il faut agir le rapport du CZ disait
qu'il faut créer un droit opposable à
l'eau au bénéfice des habitants des
autres mè mais un tel droit ne sera
effectif que si les investissements sont
réellement faits et la gouvernance rendu
efficace enfin il faudra trouver les
moyens de garantir un prix de l'eau
abordable pour tous car la pauvreté
d'une part importante de la population
ne permet pas d'envisager de les mettre
à contribution de manière massive il en
va de même sur l'assénissement la mise
au norme de l'assaainissement individuel
et hors d'atteinte des budgets de
nombreuses familles modestes il faut
prendre ces éléments en considération le
rapport de la mission sénatoriale sur
l'eau appelle donc à porter une
attention accrue à la problématique de
l'eau et de l'assainissement outrer vous
pouvez compter sur nous sur l'ensemble
de nos collègues ce rapport a fait
vraiment l'objet d'un vote unanime
transpartisan comme je vous le disais et
on peut se on peut se dire qu'on est
dans un moment où on repolitise de
manière noble le sujet de l'eau il faut
en profiter en relation avec le
gouvernement pour trouver les bonnes
voies pour pouvoir avancer et mobiliser
tous les moyens nécessaire qu'il soit
financier mais vous l'avez entendu
surtout humain je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le sénateur HERV
Gillet merci pour ce rappel enfin cet
état des lieux et puis sur ces
recommandations merci beaucoup alors on
parle de l'eau c'est un jour important
aujourd'hui à puisque a lieu la
distribution de l'eau pour tous à la
demande des élus présents ici lors de la
rencontre avec la première ministre et
le gouvernement chose promis chosees
fait messieur le sénateur vous n'allez
pas me contredire vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le sénateur au micro de public
s chez mes confrères ce matin c'est à
vous pour faire rappeler la
problématique et puis les éléments que
vous voulez nous faire partager monsieur
le sénateur tan Mohamed vos
applaudissements s'il vous
plaît merci beaucoup monsieur président
du Sénat madame la présidente de la
délégation sénatoriale aux outromè chers
collègues parlementaires Mesdames et
Messieurs les présidents d'association
d'élus Mesdames et Messieurs les maires
Mesdames et Messieurs les élus mesdames
et messieurs en vocalités
respectives je voudrais commencer mon
propos par chaleureusement remercier le
président Larcher et la délégation
sénatoriale aux outr ma à la tête de
laquelle sa président
Micheline Jacques d'avoir consacré ce
moment de solidarité à la situation à
Mayotte par rapport à à la crise de
l'eau
et je je demande aux autres collègues
élus de nous excuser pour cet espace
prix ainsi je pense que le sujet le
mérite et s'agissant de la crise de
l'eau je pense aussi à nos collègues et
à nos compatriotes de Guadeloupe et et
des autres territoires qui souffrent de
la problématique de
l'eour mais comme la situation est
extrêmement grave sur le saè département
je pense avec moi que vous admettez que
on consacre un moment très important à
cette situation vous le savez les
ressources en eau et leur gestion
représente un véritable une véritable
problématique au sein de nos territoires
ultramarin
euh depuis mai euh dernier des coupures
d'eau potable à maotte ont lieu 2 jours
de
suspension d'eau pour une réouverture le
3è jour mais qui ne dure que 18h tout au
moins c'est le dernier état lorsque
j'étais à Mayotte il y a une dizaine de
jours je ne sais pas si la situation n'a
pas
empiré parce que évidemment on adapte la
situation en fonction de la rarification
de de l'eau au fur et et à mesure les
répercussions sont nombreuses les
répercussions d'abord sur les conditions
de vie et si tout à l'heure le président
m'adisouf euh a fait une parenthèse sur
la situation de violence c'est vraiment
à raison et je voudrais à nouveau faire
cette parenthèse parce que
imaginez une
situation de
d'alimentation en eau ou de non
alimentation en eau aussi aigu aussi
grave à laquelle s'ajoute une
recrudescence mais inouie de la violence
vous avez des bandes de jeunes euh qui
profitent de cette situation pour se
faire la guéguerre j'en parle parce que
monsieur le Président nous étions venus
tous les élu de Maillotte étion venu à
votre rencontre pour nous émouvoir de
cette euh violence Inui euh ainsi que
devant la président de l'Assemblée
nationale ainsi que devant les membres
du gouvernement et bien cette situation
estedevenue la même voire pire parce que
euh ces bandes
débarquent dans un
village de façon indiscriminée s'attaque
à tout le monde incendie les voitures
incendit les maisons et
euh sans à à la population avec des
armes blanches on n'en parle pas comme
on en a parler lors de cette journée île
morte qui avait provoqué notre venue au
au auprès de vous et les forces de
l'ordre auquel il faut
euh dont il faut souligner l'engagement
font ce qu'elles peuvent mais la la la
réaction qui consiste à balancer c'est
du gaz lacrymogène de façon
indiscriminée dans les villages dans les
quartiers où il y a des enfants où il y
a des personnes âgés où il y a des
personnes
vulnérables c'est
intolérable c'est intolérable et c'est
cette situation vraiment douloureuse qui
vient s'accumuler avec cette crise de
l'eau que je voulais
ici stigmatiser devant vous pour que
nous ayons le même écho que celui que
nous avons eu euh
dans dans le passé auprès auprès de vous
je referme la parenthèse et en disant ça
parce que j'entends déjà les réactions
je ne mets pas en cause les forces de
l'ordre et leur engagement je commencer
par le le saluer mais il faut adapter il
faut changer de
doctrine pour euh que ces voyou cessent
de de de de sévire
et je vous demande solennellement de
nous aider à porter cette voix à
encourager nos forces de l'ordre et à
leur demander de changer de doctrine
parce que on ne va pas ajouter une crise
supplémentaire à d'autres crises déjà
importantes donc des répercussions
importantes sur les conditions de vie de
vie des répercussions bactériologique et
épidémio et épidémique puisque sans eau
on ne peut pas se laver on ne peut pas
se laver les mains comme on veut
et vous vous imaginez là aussi les les
conséquences sanitaires des conséquences
écologiques le gouvernement comme vous
l'avez précisé vient de commencer une
opération de distribution massive de
bouteilles d'eau plusieurs millions de
bouteilles d'eau 63 millions sont ont
été débloqués pour cela mais ces
bouteilles d'oil ne doivent pas se
retrouver dans la nature
imaginer la pollution que cela pourrait
occasionner si nous ne prenions pas
garde des conséquences écologiques et
puis les conséquences économiques n'ont
pas tardé à à se faire jour et notamment
au niveau de la restauration des
conséquences sur le fonctionnement des
services publics des écoles ont dû
fermer à plusieurs reprises parce que
les conditions d'accueil de nos gamins
n'étaient pas réuni nous sommes dans un
département
français les raisons de cette crise sont
nombreuses et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que
elles auraient pu
être mieux anticipé mais tel n'a pas été
le cas il y a d'abord la dépendance aux
pluie euh 80 % de l'eau produite à
Mayotte provient
euh des des retenues culinaires ce sont
nos bassines à nous ici si on ne veut
pas de bassine à Mayotte nous sommes
candidats pour en avoir plusieurs
et ces derniers temps l'année dernière
la saison des pluies est venue
tardivement a été très courte et a été
peu abondante c'est la première raison
qui explique qu'on en est là
et une troisème retenue collinaire qui
aurait dû voir le jour depuis des
décennies n'a pas été construite c'est
la la
retenue la troème retenue
cinaire autre raison il faut aussi se
l'avouer sans langue de bois c'est la
surpopulation du
département et
surpopulation
immédiatement et directement dû à une
immigration
incontrôlé et ici nous ne je ne
stigmatise personne mais c'est une
réalité nous avons des infrastructures
qui étaient prévu pour une certaine
quantité de population quand du jour au
lendemain vous avez une population
supplémentaire qui vient s'ajouter sans
que vous sachiez combien ni pour combien
de temps et bien ça explique aussi le
manque d'eau et c'est la même chose pour
les écoles c'est la même chose pour les
les infrastructures de de de santé la
déforestation massive Mayot un petit a
eu une petite île de 374 km² avec peu de
forêt si en plus on déforeste et bien
rien n'ira plus et puis euh un réseau de
distribution usé et mal
entretenu sachez que 1 % euh pardon
euh 1/3 1/3 de la quantité d'eau
s'éparpille dans les fuites
s'éparpie dans dans dans les fuites et
euh c'est cette problématique de gestion
euh et des
dysfonctionnements a été mise en avant
par la chambre régionale des comptes en
2018 qui a révélé des difficultés de de
gestion au sein du syndicat chargé de de
la gestion des eaux et si je dis tout
cela il faut faire le bon diagnostic euh
ce ne sont pas les médecins qui vont me
contredire ni
euh il faut faire les bons diagnostics
pour trouver les les les bonnes les
bonnes solutions la chambre régionale
des comptes a également souligné je la
cite que l'État n'avait pas suffisamment
joué son rôle de pilotage de contrôle et
d'accompagnement dans les
investissements sur les moyens de
production et le réseau alors même que
plusieurs crises de l'eau étaient déjà
survenu sa gestion des fonds européens a
fait peser un temps le risque d'une
perte d'une partie d'entre eux donc la
responsabilité de de l'État est
également
pointé du
doigt face à cette crise le le
gouvernement a a réagi par les mesures
que j'ai commencé à dont j'ai commencé à
vous parler tout à l'heure la livraison
d'eau potable depuis la réunionné depuis
la réunion j'aimerais que vous
applaudissiez nos amis
réunionnés nos amis Mauriciens aussi de
l'eau qui est venue de Maurice également
euh autre réaction d'urgence une usine
de dessalement est en train de voir le
jour à pamandi dans la commune du
président de l'association des mères euh
le prix des bouteilles d'eau a été gelé
il faut contrôler cette affaire parce
que euh il y a eu des
abus et d'autres mesures d'urgence ont
été ont été prises notamment la prise en
charge des factures d'eau entre
septembre et la fin de l'année mais
c'est à plus long terme qu'il faut
absolument que nous réagissions
collectivement à maotte et notamment en
matière de
gouvernance l'année prochaine l'office
de l'eau de Mayotte devrait voir le jour
donc en en 2000 20 24 cet organe jouera
un rôle de pilotage et d'impulsion
auprès de tous les acteurs de l'eau au
même titre que les les offices de l'eau
existant dans les quatre autres
départements d'outrom ou que les agences
de l'eau dans
l'Hexagone en matière de
distribution outre la poursuite de la
réduction du du taux de fuite il faut
absolument renforcer ce ce réseau de de
de de distribution en matière de
production euh une seconde usine de
désalinisation devait être construite en
2025 et cette usine devrait produire
10000 m³ d'eau supplémentaire la
quantité journalière c'est
43000 m C et puis surtout ce projet de
3è retenue collinaire il faut foncer
sans calculer moi je ne vois pas je ne
vois vraiment pas pourquoi certains
hésitent encore il faut absolument cette
trème retenue collinaire parce que euh
dans l'état dans les temps qui vont qui
vont venir il va de plus en plus il va
de moins en moins pleuvoir mais
lorsqu'il va pleuvoir ça sera en grande
quantité récemment nous nous l'avons vu
je crois que c'était en en Grèce en une
nuit est tombé l'équivalent d'une d'une
année de pluie donc une troisième
retenue il ne faut pas lesésiner sur les
moyens il nous la faut absolument et
pour financer ces ces tr travaux un plan
pluriannuel d'un investissement dédié de
287 millions d'euros et prévu mais j'ai
envie de dire c'est
cette cet argent
devrait être mieux utilisé on doit mieux
anticiper que nous l'avons fait jusqu'à
jusqu'à présent je conclurai mon propos
en disant que la crise maoraise et plus
généralement la situation de l'eau dans
tous les territoires ultramarin met en
évidence des faiblesses et manquement
dans plusieurs domaines une gouvernance
éclatée qui appelle à la création d'une
autorité organisatrice unique sur chaque
territoire un contrôle insuffisant des
délégataires par les collectivités et
plus
généralement les difficultés de de
gestion des autorités organisatrices il
faut qu'on se le
disent un contrôle de l'égalité
problématique de l'État une mobilisation
inefficace des crédits européens et le
volet assainissement encore plus
délaissé que celui de l'eau il apparaît
donc que face au changement climatique
même les territoires ultramarins
disposant d'une ressource en eau
abondante doivent engager des
investissements pour sécuriser cette
ressource je vous remercie de votre
attentionoup monsieur le sénateur merci
infiniment si votre merci beaucoup en
tout cas pour ce rappel de la
problématique et des recommandations si
votre collègueut compléter ou apporter
un autre point de vue c'est à vous pour
quelques minutes on va essayer de gagner
en temps pour donner aux échanges parce
que je sais que c'est vraiment très
Maillotte mais vous avez envie de
partager aussi des expériences merci
infiniment merci merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Madame la Présidente je
vais être vraiment vite bref pour aller
plus vite effectivement je m'associe
complètement à ce qui vient de dire mon
collègue tan de de ses propos et que je
vais simplement compléter et parfois
même aller à l'encontre de ce que que
certains préconisent ici et on va en
parler avec bien sûr le président parce
que nous faisons partie de la même
commission et on aura l'occasion bien
sûr d'en débattre librement comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président il faut
toujours ici être être un sénateur libre
et défendre son territoire et j'ai
retenu ça lors de votre élection alors
Mayotte fait face monsieur le Président
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant à une
crise majeure de l'eau qui annonce très
concrètement
que ce que nos territoire mararin vont
subir dans les prochaines années parce
que ça ne sera pas simplement Maillotte
mais nous sommes des îles et ça va
concerner l'ensemble de nos
collectivités
toutefois cette crise ça bas sur un
territoire le plus pauvre de la
République dont les indicateurs de
pauvreté
istrent ce fossé qui existe avec la
situation dans l'Hexagone en effet
84 % de la population à V sous le seuil
de pauvreté et pourtant c'est un
département
français de surcroix l'afflux d'une
population comme l'a dit mon collègue
tan population étrangère accentuée
accentue une poussée démographique de
plus de 4 % à l'année la plus forte de
la
République l'année
2022 a battu un record avec plus de
21000 naissances par an soit une classe
de primaire tous les jours qui n'est à
Mayotte et monsieur le Président vous
imaginez je reviens on fait de la
politique on est dans une maison
politique ici j'avais proposé un
amendement qui n'a pas été retenu
concernant bien sûr la limitation à
Mayotte qui sont des gens qui sont
assignés à résidence chez nous alors
qu'ils ont une carte de séjour ils
peuvent circuler dans toute la
République et on nous a expliqué c'était
ENF en faisant ça en laissant les gà
partir ce serait un appel d'air donc moi
j'aimerais bien ici qu'on me donne la
définition qu'est-ce que c'est un appel
d'air parce que nous avons déjà
aujourd'hui 35000 personnes qui résident
à Mayot d'une manière régulière mais qui
peuvent pas aller ailleurs alors l'appel
d'air c'est quoi je ne sais pas il faut
peut-être voir la rousse madame la
Président je compte sur toi pour me
guider là-dessus nous sommes vrai
sablblement monsieur le Président Madame
la Présidente aujourd'hui le deuxè
territoire ilultra marin en nombre
d'habitants autour de 35 à 400000
habitants alors que nous avons un
territoire de 374 km Carr avec bien sûr
une densité de
2600 à peu près habitants au kilomètre
Carr c'est incroyable les données sont
incroyables il faut prendre conscience
que cette crise découle des changements
climatiques évidemment que les experts
avaient prévu pour nos
territoire sur mon territoire de
Mayotte dans un document de stage stage
ces 11 structures de l'État et dans sa
périphérie qui sont répertoriés comme
acteur de l'eau sans compter les
collectivités c'est pourquoi quand
j'entends certains dire qu'il faut
enlever la compétence aux élus parce que
nous avons un syndic qui gère la l'eau
moi je ne suis pas d'accord comme vous
l'avez dit nous sommes ici pour défendre
les collectivités et moi je suis très
jaloux de la libre administration des
collectivités donc ce que vous vous
battez ici pour la libre administration
des collectivités il faut qu'à
mayillotte aussi nous nous soyons libres
de de de de gérer ce que nous avons à
faire ce que nous voulons c'est un appui
et vous l'avez dit un appui il est
là-bas pour pouvoir mettre en œuvre bien
sûr nos
projets l'effort de rationalisation dans
la gestion de l'eau ces dernières années
ne devrait pas concerner que les
collectivités
territoriales mais aussi les services de
l'État je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il y
en a 11 comment se fait-il que pendant
tout ce temps-là il y a pas eu je dirais
au moins la sonnette d'alarme en disant
voilà il va y avoir des difficultés et
qu'il faudrait agir
deux chiffres illustrent ce fossé
entre une gestion de l'eau en métropole
et dans mon territoire
Mayotte dans le rapport de nos deux
collègues ici près monsieur le
rapporteur est là
entre bien sûr dans le rapport de nos de
collègues il est indiqué que chaque
habitant consomme par jour en moyenne
146 l d'eau à métropole à mayott c'est
60 L
d'eau le fossé est énorme vous imaginez
c'est
énorme il y a un chiffre euh de
personnes dont non accordé de
250000 personnes qui ne sont pas
accordées sur une population vous
imaginez de 350000 estimé c'est énorme
aussi qui est sans doute une donnée
métropolitaine exclusivement à Mayotte à
partir des chiffres de l'incé 100000
habitants n'ont pas de l'eau courante
donc quand certains ici par de
résilience des maorés moi ça me touche
je je trouve que c'est manqué de respect
à la population de Mayotte ils ne
descendent pas dans la rue parce que ils
n'ont pas envie de descendre mais ils
n'ont jamais eu d'eau donc il y en a pas
donc pourquoi ils vont descendre
réclamer quelque chose qu'ils n'ont
jamais eu donc donnez-leur de l'eau vous
verrez que s'il en manque et si on nous
coupe pendant 2 jours 3 jours et ben on
descendra dans la rue parce qu'on est
habitué à avoir de l'eau mais quand vous
n'avez pas et que vous avez des favilas
un peu partout qui n'ont jamais eu de
l'eau donc comment voulez-vous demander
aux gens de descendre dans la rue quand
ils n'ont jamais eu c'est
toutau en conclusion monsieur le
Président Madame la Présidente il faut
que collectivement nous prenions à bras
le corps la question de l'eau dans nos
territoire cette crise majeure de la
ressource en nom à Mayotte aura au moins
un aspect positif c'est de permettre ce
dossier enfin qui soit mis sur le dessus
de la pile du Sénat et peut-être du
gouvernement monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur merci pour votre volonté à
travailler collectivement retiendra
alors place aux échanges je vais faire
un moyen démoc que je vais donner tout
de suite la parole au sénateur de la
Guadeloupe monsieur Victorin Lurel pour
un peu ouvrir le champ et ne pas rester
que sur Mayotte oui il n'était pas au
courant il me regarde pour un partage
c'est ça c'est la voix démocratique du
Sénat si le président du Sénat est
d'accord on est on demande tout le monde
d'intervenir et vous êtes à côté du
président donc je vous invite à prendre
la parole pour un partage puisque nous
restons pas à Mayotte mais en tout cas
cet exemple est criant et on sait qu'
qu'en Guadeloupe c'est difficile et donc
on partageons
trèsile très difficile madame je
j'emploie les mots qui dans mon rôle
bien évidemment nous compatissons et
nous comprenons votre douleur le
sénateur va donc prendre la parole pour
se faire la G il faut savoir tout faire
hein ben bien évidemment je peux vous
assurer que je n'étais pas du tout
informé que je devais prendre la parole
enfin bon sur la crise de l'eau je
disais les crises de l'eau puisque c'est
un peu différent selon les territoires
et en plus elles sont récurrentes ça ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui j'aimerais pas
vous choquer ni relativiser mais il y a
des crises de l'eau ici en province il y
en a Kathrine m'a dit pas vraiment
Martinique mais il y a des problèmes de
dysfonctionnement en Martinique c'est
vrai que c'est très très grave en
Guadeloupe très grave à à Mayotte il
faut trouver moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié
le rapport que Gill
vient Gil vient d'exposer on peut s'en
inspirer au-delà de la tion qu'il faut
le dire faute de consensus entre élu de
Guadeloupe on nous a imposé le syndicat
mixte de gestion de Louis de
l'assaainissement dewsm
gag la la coordination que tu évoque me
paraît une bonne idée enfin tu as
insisté sur une chose et c'est mon totem
on nous annonce 320 millions sur 4 ans
euh 320 millions pour régler les
problèmes de l'eau vous savez que si on
additionne tout c'est entre 1 milliard
et 1 milliard 5 si on prend les forages
de la Grande Terre qui sont qualqu qu'il
faut désaliniser il faudrait donc
beaucoup euh d'argent mais si on se
table sur un milliard on avait demandé à
l'époque au gouvernement de garantir au
moins 500 millions euh sur 30 ans euh
pour donner les moyens à ce syndicat
unique euh en ayant un peu fort c'est la
m au maire puisque on a jusque c'est
çaagile jusqu'à 2026 pour transférer ce
pouvoir de gestion de l' des communes au
aux EPCI c'est pas terminé mais en
Guadeloupe la chose est faite bon si
ouais ou elle est déjà pas non il y a en
régie certains et des conventions qui
continuent mais en fait la
centralisation a été faite et on nous
propose euh 320 millions j'ai cherché
moi dans les programmes dans les
missions dans les programmes dans les
actions dans les sous-actions j'ai pas
trouvé euh les 320 millions donc 73
millions euh pour l'État le reste c'est
l'Europe et peut-être il y aura c'est
pas peut-être obligatoirement des prêts
donc il faut être très attentif sur les
annonces c'est facile de faire des
annonces et c'est vrai que c'est une
bonne gestion que d'avoir une gestion
pluriannuelle sur plusieurs années là si
euh on on regarde à peu près les 100
millions qui avaient été donnés à
l'origine à ce syndicat il faudrait plus
de 150 ans pour régler le problème en
wadeloue bon ça veut dire que il faut
reprendre le problème et certains ont
même c'est exagéré mais certains ont
même portter plainte pour non assistance
à peuple en danger l'ONU s'est emparé de
l'affaire peut-être qu'il y a c'est
normal mais en même temps on regarde qui
a fait ça comment c'est sorti il faut
pas non plus être DUP sur un certain
nombre de chosees celui qui par un
opposant mais en même temps il faut pas
admettre n'importe quoi je suis un élu
responsable vous savez ça je dis les
choses mais c'est vrai c'est c'est ça
c'est internationalisé cette affaire- là
et donc il faut s impliqué comment
voulez-vous au moment où le président et
la délégation viennent d'inscrire l'état
outre ma quel est le rôle la mission la
présence la symbolique de l'État chez
nous et dans les ares mes en général que
l'État son représentant le préfet de
région chaque semaine réunit à peu près
se personnes il y a aucun élu
Guadeloupéens dedans alors pourtant
qu'il y a un syndicat euh le syndicat
mixte euh il y a aucun élu guadeloupéen
dedans il y a des techniciens qui sont
venus de métropole alors c'est vrai
c'est c'est symbolique c'est c'est un
vécu c'est un ressenti mais c'est vrai
que en terme de symbolique c'est mauvais
c'est très mauvais ensuite on vous
raconte le ministre monsieur Viger nous
raconte on va mettre 320 millions vous
cherchez vous ne trouvez pas
véritablement on a mis 1 milliard euh
euh pour la transition écologique on a
on a mis 250 millions euh pour la
réduction de l'utilisation des produits
phytopharmaceutiques bref les pesticides
et on a mis euh je sais plus combien euh
dans lesmissions sur l'eau notamment
dans lesémission de euh du ministère de
la transition écologique il faut voir
c'est disperser partout on nous dit
alors dans la mission outreem il y a
quelqu argent notamment sur le FEI sur
le fond d'investissement euh euh des des
outre bon on va voir pour le moment moi
je veux avoir et j'espère avoir cette
réponse avant le 7 décembre sur le
contrôle des sénateur c'est bien le 7
décembre que la mission est examinée en
séance publique de vérifier ce qui nous
est proposé voilà ce que je peux vous
dire nous sommes vigilants ici au Sénat
au-delà de ce que fait le gouvernement
c'est son droit c'est même son devoir
que de faire la publicité de sa
politique mais c'est aussi notre devoir
que de contrôler le Sénat fait beaucoup
d'évaluations et beaucoup de contrôle
c'est peut-être ça c'est pas peut-être
c'est certainement la force du Sénat
monsieur le Président euh de faire
beaucoup de rapports de faire des lois
bien rédigées et je finis sur une chose
euh on m'a trouvé un peu critique et je
n'ai pas pu aller samedi à la à la au
colloc sur la révision institutionnelle
c'est vrai que j'avais un autre chantier
qui était à la demande des partis de
gauche d'aller euh euh défiler dans les
rues pour la paix et la justice entre
les peuples Israéliens et Palestiniens
j'y suis allé
euh c'est pas donc un refus mais en même
temps je dis à mes compatriotes puisque
ça a été dans la première séquence et je
m'arrête là parce que je suis déjà eu
trop long que nous devons être bons en
légistique on a demandé au Sénat à nous
aider sur ce travail le président ouvert
un chantier sur la différenciation sur
la venir euh des communes mathed
d'Arnaud a exposé euh ce matin euh
au-delà de de tout ce que l'on peut dire
de tous les nos professeurs il nous
manque des légistes des gens rédigeant
la loi et et la rédigeant bien en
guadeloup on a parlé beaucoup la
délégation a fait un travail
considérable qu'il faut vraiment estimer
et peut-être porter et peut-être
transformer en amendement dont une une
PPLC avec un article 6 sur la fusion du
73 et du 74 ou alors et je finis là à
inscrire dans le 72 avec une déclinaison
à loadque ce que le président Larcher a
évoqué dans son propos voilà quelques
mots improvisés merci beauoup monsieur
sénateur on a donc bien fait de vous
donner la parole il y a une question ici
le maire de La Réunion le maire du port
monsieur Warot sous l'œil vigilant de
son président d'association des maires
donc voilà qui va prendre la parole
merci bienveillant bonjour à tous à
toutes monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs les sénatrices les élus les
maires et et représentant des
collectivités euh merci de me donner la
parole je voudrais euh
euh témoigner euh d'une part sur le
soutien euh euh que la réunion peut
apporter à Mayotte et c'est tout à fait
normal euh mais euh je voulais
intervenir sur la question de l'eau de
manière euh générale c'est vrai que nous
nous attardons sur des situations de de
rattrapage et c'est urgent euh d'agir
d'aller de concrétiser de mettre en
place les réseaux il y a aussi un sujet
qui est celui de la préservation de la
ressource en eau vous savez avec le
changement climatique nous sommes tous
plus ou moins concernés et même au
niveau
national à la question de la sécheresse
de nos rivières des lacs et si nous
n'avons pas une gestion anticipée de la
réfaction de des des nappes des de la
ressource nous arrivons nous arriverons
à de grandes de calamité vous savez
l'humanité s construire autour s
construite autour des cours d'eau elle
peut disparaître s'il n'y a plus d'eau
donc à la Réunion et au port je porte
depuis quelques années une
expérimentation sur la réutilisation des
EAU grises c'est un concept qui a été
repris dans le plan haut de du présenté
par le gouvernement cette année une
expérimentation qui a déjà montré toutes
les garanties sur la capacité à
réutiliser une eau traitée filtré pour
les arrosages publics et pour l'usage
industriel moi ce qui me choque encore à
la Réunion et au port c'est de fabriquer
du béton avec de l'eau potable quand je
vois mes amis de Mayotte ça me fait mal
au cœur qu'on fabrique et qu'on arrose
et je suis concerné puisque je suis
maire des terrains de foot avec de l'eau
de l'eau quasi potable même potable et
que je vois en face à quelques heures
d'avion là aussi des des grandes
difficultés sur la gestion de cette eau
et même sur notre territoire sur l'Est
par exemple où on a les les les les les
les des des cultures mon ami de
Saint-Benoît confirme qui sont
confrontés à aux périodes de sécheresse
il y a urgence à faire évoluer la
réglementation sur la réutilisation des
eaux grises il y a une j'espère une
évolution réglementaire il serait temps
que
l'ARS dans nos régions soit un peu plus
courageuse je le dis parce que c'est
souvent l'ouverture du parapluie
pardonnez-moi le le le lien avec l'eau
celui-ci mais il y a une une une une une
peur
administrative que je peux comprendre
mais quand je regarde en
Australie quand je regarde en Israël en
Afrique du Sud en Californie on arrive à
consommer de l'eau réutilisée enfin je
veux dire nous les élus d'outrem de la
réunon on n'est pas plus bête queeux on
sait faire on a déjà expérimenté donc il
serait temps qu'on puisse aller de
l'avant et que peut-être aussi et je
vous terminerai sur cette sur cette ce
lien avec le sujet de Mayotte que l'eau
réutilisée sur notre territoire préserve
la ressource et cette ressource soit
aussi préservée pour venir encore en
soutien à notre au territoire amis dans
l'océan Indien merci à vous merci
beaucoup Monsieur le Maire Olivier OOT
alors il y a la réponse de monsieur le
sénateur Hervé gilet et ensuite des
intervention également qui était
présente messieur madame voilà monsieur
le sénateur oui très rapidement par
rapport à par rapport à l'intervention
bon il commence à y avoir des évolutions
hein il commence à y avoir des
évolutions pour ce qui s'agit de l'ARS
théoriquement la préconisation
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il doivent donner
un avis et s'il ne le donnent pas à ce
moment-là le projet qui est déposé est
réputé valider
donc là il y a une inversion parce que
jusqu'à maintenant quand il donnait pas
d'avis le projet n'était pas accepté
donc il commence à y avoir une inversion
aujourd'hui au niveau du sujet les
fameux décrets sur la réutilisation des
eaux grises et des eaux usées la reute
les fameux décrets commenent à sortir
aussi et notamment on a des gains de
productivité très fort en terme de
consommation d'eau dans toutes les
filières aussi agroalimentaires et
cetera et c'est très attendu à l'heure
actuelle et enfin ils ont beaucoup tardé
ils commencent à sortir donc il commence
à y avoir des signaux vraiment
favorables je va pas aller plus loin
pour préserver les questions merci
beaucoup monsieur le sénateur merci vous
pouvez applaudir pour la réponse s'il
vous plaît alors il y a la la madame qui
et ensuite monsieur j'ai bien noté vous
AZ encore deux monessieurs ici si vous
voulez bien passer le micro à à Madame
et vous déclinez votre identité merci
beaucoup oui bonjour monsieur le
Président archer merci de nous recevoir
je suis Christine oublon je suis
conseillère municipal à ville des habis
mais deè président de l'association des
mers de guadeloup j'ai une demande ou
une question je ne comprends pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui l'État a pris en
maain à retirer au communauté d'agloot
la gestion de l'eau l'état pris en main
par la loi d'accord je dis l'état
général hein bon nos parlementaires et
voilà et le gouvernement vous savons
aujourd'hui la Guadeloupe et je je suis
solidaire un petit peu de la souffrance
de mes compatriotes de de Mayotte c'est
vrai mais en Guadeloupe nous n'avons pas
de problème de manque d'eau d'ailleurs
la Guadeloupe c'est l'île au Bell
le problème c'est un problème de
d'argent j'ai envie de le dire très
simplement en me faisant le porte-parole
du citoyen lambda en Guadeloupe si
puisque l'État a pris cette gestion en
mettant ce ce cette voilà ce syndicat et
cetera pourquoi l'État ne met pas les
moyens financiers qu'il faut pour régler
ce problème de l'eau une fois pour
toutes l'eau c'est la vie si on veut
vraiment défendre le citoyen
guadeloupéen il faut y mettre les moyens
alors messieurs les sénateurs ce que
nous vous demandons pour la Guadeloupe
et aussi pour Mayotte bon je ne peux pas
dire pour euh qui est de l'eau mais au
moins faire en sorte que sur le plan
financier sur le plan budgétaire l'État
met en place l'argent qu'il faut pour
régler très rapidement cette ce problème
ce n'est pas possible que dans un
département français où il y a de l'eau
simplement pour des questions euh
d'entretien d'assainissement et j'ai
envie de dire qu'en tant que citoyenne
nous nous avons payé à l'époque sur nos
factures d'eau il y avait des retenu
pour l'entretien des canalisations et de
l'assainissement ça n'a pas été utilisé
il y a eu voilà alors réparons pour que
le guadoupéen puisse vivre
convenablement comme tous les citoyens
français merci etieur je compte sur vous
au niveau du Sénat il faut le faire
merci beaucoup pour votre intervention
place aux autres interventions
oui VO là-bas monsieur et Monsieur voilà
oui merci Didier méridan conseiller
municipal de la ville des abîes mais
aussi ex-membre du conseil
d'administration du comité syndical du
smgag c'est vrai je fais partie de ces
élus qui ont démissionné parce que
effectivement quand on est face à la
population et que la menace on est
menacé parce que elle est exaspérée pour
de l'eau qui ne coule pas dans le
robinet et une facture qui ne varie pas
eau ou sans eau nous payons la même
somme donc c'est aussi avec mon collègue
William surdin des opérations où on se
rencre aujourd'u que ce sont les élus
qui doivent porter l'eau et que nous
avons pas le soutien forcément des
administratifs si c'est pas le rôle
d'une commune c'est le rôle de celui qui
a été délégué de mettre en place
distribution d'eau compte que cette
tâche est relé au niveau des communes
sans budget et nous devons
faire et qui doit faire à ce moment ce
sont les élus et quand la population est
mécontente qui subissont encore les
violences ce sont les élus c'est bien
beau d'avoir un statut mais de est-ce
que je porterai plainte contandre on
administré qui n'a pas d'eau et qui est
exaspéré depuis 50 ans de cette
souffrance ça invite à réfléchir puisque
nous parlons d'eau effectivement la
collègue disait qu'on avait pas de
problème d'eau sur le territoire mais
pensez-vous que quand la RS fait un
contrôle le mardi et que le vendredi
elle nous dit que l'eau n'est pas
potable c'est vrai qu'on l' regardé
entre-temps on l'a bien consommé
pourquoi aujourd'hui on n'a pas sur
notre territoire un institut qui permet
au aujourd'hui de faire en moins de 48
he un contrôle de l'eau pour pouvoir
être au plus près des éléments de
sécurité qu'elle doit exercer sur le
territoire c'est pas le cas c'est
peut-être pas grand-chose
nous on ne k pas là on dit simplement
que la RS aujourd'hui un obligation de
de préserver la vie elle doit le faire
en 48 he ou en 24 heures mais pourquoi
la fiole doit partir sous l'Hexagone
pourevenenir 72 he après pour nous dire
qu'elle est pas potable c'est pas
normal nous avons a besoin effectivement
de comprendre qu'on met en place un tour
d'eau quand une canalisation est en
pression qu'on coupe l'eau et qu' a des
fuite qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle
absorbe l'eau qui est dans la terre elle
va prendre les microbes et après qu'on
renvoie l'eau on envoie une eau qui est
validée par la r sortie d'usine mais qui
est pollué au robinet de la population
pourtant c'est pas de l'argent qu'on
demande c'est du bon sens donc là aussi
oui on retrouve de l'eau boueuse de
l'eau Maron robiné c'est vrai c'est pas
le cas de Mayotte
peut-être si c'est non mais je veux dire
je je je j'ai fait une petite ironie là
euh mais je pense que nous partageons
les mêmes problèm à des degrés
différents nous sommes aujourd'hui le
sol département peut-être là encore une
primeure à avoir une dérogation du
ministère du ministre des autres maires
pour faire passer de de l'investissement
monter en fonctionnement 25 millions
d'euros contionnés par la région 25
millions contionnés par le département
et 23 millions donnés par l'État oui 73
millions d'euros comme a dit le sénateur
qui l'a financé c'est nous-même quand on
conne 25 million d'euros c'est aussi
deinvestissement que la région et le
département ne pourit pas faire pour
d'autrre
sujet donc je vais pas être plus long
parce que j'ai fort à dire sur le sujet
puisque c'est un sujet que je suis
depuis longtemps et quand effectivement
une gouvernance à qu se met en place et
que nous au niveau du Comité Syndical on
nous oppose des documents déjà signés
qu'on doit voter c'est un manque de
respect au niveau des élus locaux merci
merci pour votre
intervention vous voulez oui madame la
présidente madame la Présidente oui je
je tiens particulièrement à
remercier notre collègue Saïd qui doit
s'absenter justement parce qu'il a des
des amendements à défendre donc merci
infiniment cher Saïd et bon courage
merci de l'applaudir et de lui souhaiter
de bons travaux merci beaucoup monsieur
le sénateur alors nous nous avions oui à
vous si allez-y ok monsieur le sénateur
euh je je je te garantis je suis pas là
pour dissoudre la syndicat deso
hein mesdames
Messieurs Je je je je je vais essayer de
de compléter ce que ce qu' on dit nos
sénateurs je le le maire du port et
certains intervenants Rachad Saindou
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de Mayotte
cademma je suis pas maire mais je suis
je quasiment le premier je suis le
président d'agglomération qui n'est pas
mère pour répondre à la problématique de
l'alimentation en N sur notre territoire
implique une action urgente car notre
population toute entière souffre nous
devons également trouver des solutions
écologiques économiques durables et
fiables voici quelques éléments de
réflexion et quelques actions que
l'académa met en œuvre de manière très
concrète utilisons notre taux
hygrométrie élevée le taux d'humidité
moyen s'élève sur not territoire à 80 %
le jour et 95 % la nuit utilisons l'air
comme ressource les réserves d'air sont
inépuisables renouvelables et
omniprésentes la cadem c'est équipée de
dé générateurs d'eau atmosphérique sur
chacun de ces site administratif de
mamouzu et dembi chaque générateur
produit jusqu'à environ 100 l d'eau afin
d'assurer les besoins à NS des agents et
des élus parce que aujourd'hui à Mayotte
on ferme nos bureaux à 11h c'est pour
éviter tout ça
l'academa souhaite développer cette
ressource en eau potable qui se
dégrade si se dégrade pas le milieu
naturel sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire afin de faire face
aujourd'hui est domain à la crise de
l'eau et de proposer à l'ensemble de sa
population des solutions concrètes
fiable et écologique l'academa vient de
lancer un marché pour la fourniture
livraison installation et mise en
service de quatre générateurs en eau
atmosphérique sur une production
journalière minimale de 5 ml avec deux
installations à mamouzou chef-lieu et
deux à
dembi cet e produit pourra être utilisé
dans un premier temps comme en eau
ménagèr par la population en attendant
une validation de ministère de la Santé
et de la RS courant 2024 pour
utilisation comme anneau destiné à la
consommation humaine s'il vous plaît
madame dans le cadre de cette opération
l'academma
prévoit une dépense d'un million d'euros
pour mise en service de qu installations
courantes mai 2024
l'alimentation des générateurs se fera
dans un premier temps de manière
électrique mais nous souhaitons très
vite passer à un système hybride pour
répondre un défi de la transition
écologique et énergétique à ce titre
madame l'academma prévoit d'équiper
chaque site d'un complexe d'alimentation
solaire d'une sur d'une surface de
panneau solaire d'environ 300 m² et puis
nous allons aussi occuper d'aut un autre
projet qui vient d'être lancé
sur nos rivières parce que il y a des ns
rus seulement parce qu'il y a de l'eau
dans nos dans nos dans notre territoire
on a on a détecté 11 sites donc
aujourd'hui nous avons lancé et marché
dans ce sens pour donner de l'eau à
notre population aujourd'hui l'État
donne de l'eau potable des bouteilles de
l'eau c'est une très bonne chose mais
aujourd'hui face à cela les EPCI ont
cette compétence aussi monsieur le
sénateur de Gironde nous nous avons on
n'a pas entendu cette transfert nous on
est on est déjà là parce qu'il y a une
crise merci merci pour votre
intervention alors si vous en êtes
d'accord le temps est imparti je vais
vous demander d'applaudir cette séquence
les intervenants de cette table ronde
merci beaucoup demander à merci
infiniment mais les sénateurs demander à
la présidente de la délégation madame
lichinjac de faire les mots de
conclusion mais vous rappelez si
monsieur le Président on est d'accord
peut-être vous voulez également faire un
mot de conclusion après celle de madame
la Présidente non tout va bien le FR en
vous recevant tous très bien parfait
alors ne partez pas juste vous dire
qu'après c'est parfait monsieur le
Président en tout cas vous savez qu'il y
a ce grand rendez-vous qui vous attend
nous allons écouter madame la Présidente
et inviter le président du Sénat ainsi
que les sénateurs et les intervenants
pour une photo finale mais avant de
donner la parole à madame la Présidente
remercier les équipes techniques les
équipes de la communication les équipes
de la délégation tromè qui ont uvré à
cette séquence l'ensemble des équipes
pour que vous puissiez tous échanger et
merci de votre attention pour les
conclusions de madame la sénatrice s'il
vous plaît madame madame minj c'est à
vous merci s'il vous plaît merci je
voulais bon tan a dû partir parce qu'ils
ont aussi des amendements à défendre
mais je voulais à travers cette table
ronde montrer tout le soutien de la
délégation et du Sénat à la population
maoraaise puisque nous mesurons dans
quelle dans quelle difficulté les
difficultés qu'elle traverse
actuellement et il est vrai que au nom
de l'unité au nom de la fraternité mais
surtout du respect de la dignité humaine
il me semblait vraiment primordial
d'être à l'écoute et de montrer notre
solidarité non seulement aux Maura mais
à toutes ces population que ce soit
aussi de la la Guadeloupe qui vivent au
quotidien ces problématiques d'eau donc
nous arrivons au terme de de cette
matinée et qui a été particulière
riche et je tiens à vous remercier tous
je remercie particulièrement mes
collègues qui sont partis mais qui ceux
qui qui ont été courageux et qui sont
restés mon cher Robert roui George
naturel Vivian
met sol Solange nadil Victor Lurel
Catherine Cancon Hervé gilet et tous les
autres qui ont dû quitter parce comme
l'a dit fort justement Catherine comme
tout à l'heure le Sénat continue à
fonctionner malgré toute cette activité
foisonnante que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui consacrés aux outres mèes
donc ce sont des temps d'échange qui ont
été très importants et en tant que en
qualité de sénateur nous sommes et je le
répète les porte-paroles des
collectivités donc que ce qui suppose de
travailler étroitement avec vous sur les
problématiques que vous connaissez au
plus près des réalités des territoires
et c'est vraiment l'ADN du Sénat donc
n'hésitez pas la délégation que j'ai
l'honneur de présider depuis le 9
novembre dernier va rester à l'écoute de
vos préoccupations conformément à sa
vocation notre programme de travail pour
la présente session comportera beaucoup
de sujets qui ont été évoqués et je
souhaite naturellement que ce
rendez-vous soit pérénisé qu'il puisse
se renouveler chaque année en ouverture
du congrès des maires en coordination à
avec l'AMF je veux vous remercier tous
très sincèrement de votre présence de la
qualité de nos échanges je sais que
peut-être certains ont pu être frustrés
parce que nous étions pris par le temps
mais comme l'a annoncé le président
l'archer il vous attend à l'Orangerie
donc ce sera aussi un moment de
convivialité où nous pourrons échanger
sur les sujets que vous auriez souhaiter
évoquer avec moi ou avec les collègues
encore merci finiment et puis bonne fin
de bonne fin de soirée merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente je vais appeler le
président du Sénat ainsi que les
sénateurs monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président si vous voulez bien venir
pour la photo finale avec les sénateurs
la présidente de délégation ah d'accord
vous ah d'accord bon ben si la sénatrice
voilà c'est pas grave c'est une séquence
de photos la la
Polynésie mène le
là d'accord ok bon ben alors en tout cas
les intervenants et les sénateurs restez
parmi nous nous avons nous allons faire
la la photo avec la présidente
de mais c'est
magnifique
W monsieur voilà il donne plein de
colliers très bien non mais c'est bien
c'est bien mais juste après il faut pas
qu'il parte madame la sénatrice
le